Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
Oh, I'm just... I'm already a little tired.
I had a long day today.
Yes!
Oh, man.
Um, I haven't had my haircut done in a long time.
And I was busy.
I knew I was, like, gonna be really busy.
Um, I was gonna... I was... I was gonna be really busy the last couple of days because I wanted to get it early on Sunday because I was like, you know, Sunday's my rest day.
Usually I get stuff, like, things I want to do to treat myself on Sunday.
But then, like, um, the hair salon was, like, fully... The hair salon I liked to go was fully booked and everything.
On Sunday!
So I was like, Monday!
And then it was also fully booked.
Today I was like, I'll take anything.
I was like, I'll take anything.
And they're like, what about Thursday?
And I was like, yay, Thursday!
Yay!
Um, so yeah, I haven't gone to the hair salon in a long time because I got really lazy.
Um, you know, because it's, like, I'm always inside.
I don't... I don't really have to worry about getting my hair cut because I'm always inside.
But then... And also, like, for women, hair salons are, like, really, really fucking expensive, too.
And they also take forever.
So, like, usually when I go to the hair salon, it's when I need to, like, um, retouch my roots.
Um, it's when I, like, retouch the roots, uh, for... to dye my hair.
And then, you know, since I'm dyeing my hair anyway, um, I might as well cut my hair as well.
So, you know, get, like, you get two things done at the same time.
So, um, for those who don't know, uh, the reason why I dye my hair, um, is because, um, since I...
My parents, uh, I use, like, I don't... I don't... I use, like, the expensive hair dyes, too.
Um, so my hair is a little healthier.
Like, you know?
I use the expensive hair dyes.
Like, I ask to get, like, the, you know, the healthier ones.
So that it doesn't ruin your hair as easily.
Because I've been dyeing... My parents have been taking me, um, to dye my hair since I was a child.
Since I was, like, I think, like, eight, I think.
Um, since I was eight, I've been dyeing my hair.
Because I have a genetic defect where, um, uh, my hair, uh, my hair cannot...
Uh, my hair sometimes run out of color.
When, um, sometimes run out of color.
So, like, you know, it's like a printer.
So, it starts printing color and then it starts printing black and white ink because it runs out of like color ink.
So, like the pigment.
Yeah.
So, it's not like I have like white hair.
But it's like it will start growing black hair.
And then like at the end of the... and then like then it will suddenly turn into white hair.
And then... So, so like there's just not enough like black hair.
There's not enough black ink in my body for my pigments.
So, I have like this little genetic defect that does that.
So, this has been happening since I was a little kid.
Not since I was eight.
It was even like when I was younger.
Like maybe when I, you know, I just... it's been happening since I was a little kid.
So, so my parents, my mom was like I don't like that.
I want my child to look like a freak, cause like, you know, white hair is more noticeable on black hair.
So then my mom was like, I don't like that.
So then, that's when I started getting my hair dyed.
Because, you know, cause like, they wanted me to be a normal child.
So then, like, obviously, you know, so I've been getting my hair dyed since then.
And it was that time where I had to re-dye my hair, because like, my roots were showing a lot.
And then, because I don't get like, black, I get like, I get like, lighter colors.
And, um, I had to re-dye, and I was like, also my hair was getting like, really, really long.
So I was like, well, time to chop off half that hair, because it's summertime.
And that, and then it gets really, really hot during the summer.
So I had to like, chop off the hair.
And then like, you know, last time, I think like, the last time I went to the hair salon was like, mm, I don't remember.
It was like, I think it was like, November, November.
It was like around November that it was the last time I got my hair cut.
And so obviously it was time to do it again.
All over again.
Yeah.
So I was like, well, time to pay a couple of hundred dollars.
Yippee!
And that's why I don't visit the salon very often.
And also I have to sit there for three plus hours.
And I don't talk to the stylist because I'm not into that.
I don't like it when they talk to me.
I just look at my phone and just like... I just look at my phone and like just get my work done.
Yes, for those who don't know, for the men out there.
Um...
I know you guys, you just sit on your chair and then 15 minutes later, it's done.
For me, as a woman, I sit on the chair.
We discuss what we want to do for like 5 to 10 minutes while you guys are like done with your haircut.
I...
We sit on a chair for like 5 to 10 minutes.
And then, um...
And then they're like, do you want it layered?
Oh, what?
How do you want to style it?
You were like, okay, how short?
Okay, what do you want to do with the side bangs?
And then at that point, I was like, you know, I don't really care as much.
I just go like, um...
What do you think looks best?
And then I'd be, and they're like, oh, we should do this and that.
And then this.
And I'm like, cool.
Okay, we'll do that.
And now, and I would say, yes, get it layered.
Because I'm like, if I'm paying for an expensive...
Fucking haircut.
Like, I might as well...
Get it layered.
Because they don't add on to that.
Like, I'm like...
Well, I would not say no to getting it layered.
Because it's like a base price.
And then...
It's a base price for cuts.
So I was like, I might as well get it layered.
Because I'm already paying for an expensive haircut.
Most of the money is on the hair dye, by the way.
The hair dye...
Was a lot.
The haircut was not expensive as the hair dye.
And then so like, after that, I sat on a chair for an hour...
Almost an hour and a half of her putting hair dye in my hair.
And like, that was like an hour and a half of my time.
That...
I just...
Sat there...
For an hour and a half while she was putting all the dye in my head.
And then...
And then after that...
Um...
After that...
Shampooing it.
Like, and I have to wait even more.
After...
You know, I have to wait like 30 plus minutes.
After the hair dye was fully...
To wait for the hair dye to fully set in.
And then it's like...
Shampoo time!
Yay!
And that was another 15 to 20 minutes.
Of her like, you know, massaging my head.
And...
I mean...
Massaging my head and putting like two to three products on my hair.
And then after that...
We finally got to the cutting portion.
Then we get to the cutting portion.
And I have a lot of hair.
I grow hair really, really fast.
So like, I always have to like ask them to like...
Um...
Trim it.
So that it's like...
Lighten...
Oh, I like...
To make it less heavy.
So I'll be like...
Oh, can you like...
Lighten it up?
Why did they...
Don't they cut...
No!
Because...
That's a waste...
Oh wait...
Why don't they...
Because...
Um...
Because they want to make sure...
It like...
Um...
Sets everywhere or some sh...
I don't fucking know.
I...
No one make sure it sets everywhere...
Everywhere I guess.
I don't fucking know why they don't...
Uh...
Don't cut first.
Um...
Anyway...
I'm not a fucking hair stylist.
I don't fucking know.
I...
Um...
Anyway...
And then after that...
Then...
They cut my hair!
And then they have to blow dry and style it.
And then that was like...
Almost $200.
That...
No...
Actually it was like...
With tax it was more than $200.
It was...
It was more than $200.
And that's why I go to the hair salon...
Every couple of months...
Later.
When I need to.
That's why...
When my hair gets too long...
I go to the hair salon.
And then that is the correct time...
For me to re-dye my hair as well.
Um...
God...
Being a girl...
Expensive.
It's because the hair dye I use...
Is also like...
Healthier hair dye.
So like...
It's not like the cheap hair dye...
Where it could like...
Hurt your hair.
Um...
It's the more expensive...
Dye.
So that...
It doesn't ruin your hair.
Even if you like...
You know...
If you're like...
Especially me...
Cause I have to dye my hair every so often.
Uh...
Ooh la la...
Dad gets fancy food.
I get...
Fancy mandatory haircuts.
I don't even want to be there for.
Ooh la la...
Yeah...
If you want quality...
You got...
You gotta pay...
Um...
It's not mandatory though.
Well...
It is sort of, because, you know, I don't want to ruin my hair.
And also, like, you'll find out why I had to get, like, my hair cut, too.
You know when I said, like, I have an announcement next week?
The announcement got moved up in two days.
So you'll find out on Saturday why...
You'll find out.
Yeah, I dropped this on Mario Mon when nobody's really here.
Sex to those dragoons who don't have... Sex to those dragoons who didn't catch the Mario Mon stream.
The part six of Mario Mon.
I always drop the most important stuff, like, in the most obscure streams.
I... That's on them.
It's a random part six of Mario Mon.
But in two days, you'll find out what the special announcement is.
Instead of next week, I was told, like, yesterday night, that I was like, oh, yeah, announcement's on the 31st.
And I was like, oh, shit, that's really sad.
But you'll find out.
You can go and do your guesses if you want to.
But I'm not going to tell you what it is.
Um...
Baby, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Big J, did you listen to the gossip?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
And no, I was literally just on my phone doing work stuff.
My manager was like, did you sign a contract?
And I was like, no, I'm on my phone.
At the hair salon.
And my manager was like, oh.
After your stream, remember to sign the contract.
And I was like, okay.
Many thank you, super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Just leaving a super here, have a good stream .
sin you, thank you!
Sure thank you.
Super chat this you, thank you.
Paul did reveal thank you the Super chat, did you?
Thank you!
Did you read the contract I'm gonna sign it!
Alright, so that was mostly my day for today.
Alright, dad update.
The usual dad update.
So dad's been a little shit lately.
I say while he's like right next to me sleeping.
So, okay, so you guys remember that story of the time dad fell in love with a lady owner?
And how I tried to make him leave the dog park.
And when I made him leave the dog park, he sat there looking out the door being like, oh, I want to see her.
Please, don't let me leave.
I want to see her.
Remember that time when I was like, yeah, I've never had him like that obsessed before.
Where he had, he like sat at the door looking out in the glass, wanting to go back outside.
Um, anyway.
Anyway, we saw her again last night.
Or not last night, night.
Um, after the, uh, night rain stream, you know, I took him for the walk at the dog park.
And then, so I was at the dog park for like more than 30 minutes.
But he, cause he refused to poop.
Because all he wanted to do was spend time with the pretty lady.
Cause like he like instantly like ran to her and was like, yeah, I missed you.
Oh my God, I thought I'd never see you again.
And he actually like rolled on his back for belly rubs to her.
Like instantly.
He's like, oh my God, it's been so long.
I thought I'd never see you again.
Please rub my belly.
Touch me.
And then I literally had to sit on the bench and just like watch her like pet him.
And have him, and him following her around for like 30 plus minutes.
And then the lady was like, oh, come on.
You go poop and then I'll pet you more.
And he like refused to like leave her side.
And at that point, I gave up.
Because I was like, I have things to do.
And I was no...
I, look, I just sat on the bench on my phone.
Because I knew it was gonna be a while.
And I was not gonna bother with that.
I was like, alright, I guess if he's gonna do this, at least let me be productive.
And do stuff on my phone.
Do my work stuff.
Because he's gonna be there for a while.
So I thought, you know, he's gonna poop in those 30 plus minutes.
Because I was like, you know what?
I have some time to spare.
To like, um, to be at the dog park.
I have time to spare.
And just like, wait for him.
To like, finish, you know, with the pretty lady.
And then, you know, do his business.
And then we could leave.
But, 30 plus minutes passed.
And he was still following her around.
Begging her to touch him.
And then, at that point, I was like, okay.
I didn't realize it was gonna, he was gonna still do this.
Because I don't have a lot of time in my schedule.
I, I just, I wanted to treat him a little bit.
To have some fun times.
But, like, this fun times was taking way too long.
Like, at one point, a giant, like, he came back to me.
Because he was like, he was like, hey, do you wanna pet me?
I see you by yourself.
Doki, do you wanna pet me too?
And then, this big dog walked over to us.
And, like, started sniffing dad.
And dad was not happy about that.
Because he hates giant dogs.
He hates, he hates dogs that are bigger than him.
Because, I don't know, I guess he wants to be the biggest dog.
And so, he's like, what is this abomination?
Like, how dare you be bigger than me?
So that, you know, he gave the big dog a false...
Except for that white dog.
Except for that one white dog that likes to lick his ears.
He hates every other big dog.
Anyway.
Um.
So, like, this other...
It was like a poodle.
Like, I don't know.
He just fucking hates poodles.
I don't know.
Like, but, and there's a lot of poodles.
I asked my friend, like, why do people love owning those, like, giant poodles?
Like, those, like, poodle terrier dogs.
And, like, the min...
You know, the mini poodle terrier dogs.
And then the big poodle terrier dogs.
Not, like, the poodle poodle, but the poodle terriers.
And then I was like, oh, man.
Like, I don't understand.
Like, I don't know.
I don't...
I personally don't think they're that pretty.
But, like, apparently they don't shed as much.
That's why.
Yeah, they don't shed that much.
But I personally don't find them that pretty.
Anyway, the big ones walked up to dad and then, you know, dad gave him a false sense of security and let him get close and the moment he got near his face, he was like... And then it scared the shit out of the big dog that he actually fell backwards.
And ran away.
He actually fell backwards on his ass and ran away.
Because it, like, freaked him out.
And then dad just looked at me and was like, yeah, that's right, bitch.
Like, he did one giant fart at the big dog and then looked back at me as if nothing was to happen.
And then...
Anyway.
Yeah, and then the big dog ran away like a little bitch.
Back to his owner because he was like, what the fuck happened?
Anyway.
So, I was like, alright.
Time's up.
You're not...
You're not gonna poop.
I'm just gonna head back to my apartment.
So, the thing about this dog part is that it's sort of connected to my building.
So, you can, like, go there by going through my building.
We still have to walk a little bit there.
So, like, you know, I walked out and then headed to the...
Headed to my building.
And walked through the hallway of my building.
And this little fuckhead, when we got to the hallway, pooped in the middle of the hallway.
Because he was like, oh, wait.
I was supposed to poop.
And I was like, are you fucking kidding me?
I was like, you had so much time.
And you're like, oh, you know what?
Oh, you're right.
I should have pooped.
Well, I might as well poop now.
And then I...
Oh, my God.
I was like, oh, my God.
Why?
I was like, why?
You had so much time.
It's like, well, he's like, lady gone.
Might as well poop here now.
Like...
And then, so I had to like, you know, it was so embarrassing.
Because like, okay, I got really scared.
Because, you know, my apartment building has like, a rule where obviously if they find out that you poop inside the building, I get fined $50.
So I was like, I like quickly picked it up and like, I quickly picked it up and like, walked back to the dog park to throw the poop away.
And then, lad got really happy.
He was like, I get to see her again!
Yay!
Because he saw me turn around back to the dog park.
And he was like, yay!
Yay!
I'll get to see her again!
I am...
All part of the plan.
And then, yeah.
And then I...
And then like, at that point, the lady was actually about to leave when I threw away the poop.
And he's like, that's alright!
Oh, you're leaving too?
Yay!
And then like, she actually lived in my building too.
So she was like, oh, oh, oh, hey, I hear you're like...
But then the thing is, she has to do the other elevator.
So like, the right...
So like, the elevator is divided between floors.
So she was on a different floor than me.
So then, dad tried to follow her to the different elevator.
And he was like, come on!
Why are you like, come on?
I was like, come back!
I was like, no!
No!
And I had to pick him up because he refused to leave that elevator.
He was like, but she's going to this elevator.
And I was like, get out!
You're not following her home!
And he's like, no!
I want to be in this elevator!
And he knows he's in the wrong elevator.
Because he knows, like, which one, which side is the correct one.
Because it's like, like, one side's left and the other side's right.
And he's never gone on the other side before.
So he knows it's the wrong elevator.
He's not stupid.
Like...
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's okay.
We all know how you feel.
Boy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Obscure, yes.
And all while doing while wearing a Mario cap and massage.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Dominic, thank you for the super chat.
Hey, Dinklebird.
I want to wish you a good stream.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Not so Deadpool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Are you sure he's not part of Shih Tzu?
Oh my god, no, he's a purebred wiener dog.
Acting like a real weenie right now.
Duck, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Got pet by a pretty lady like a boss.
Bullied a big dog like a boss.
Took a dump in the hallway like a boss.
Saw the pretty lady again like a boss.
Anyway, that's the dad update.
Final update.
I finally have my third monitor installed.
That's why you see me looking to the right again because the third monitor is finally installed.
It is double the size of my main two monitors because my main two monitors are the same monitor.
And then my third monitor is the one that MSI sent me.
And then it is double the size.
It took... I'll show you guys a picture of it later because I need like sensor stuff, obviously.
But like I showed a picture of it to like my manager because my manager was like, Oh, did you install your... finally install your third monitor?
Because they're planning on sending you another one later.
And I was like, yeah.
It like took me like three bricks to get it fully installed.
Yeah, it's the... I think it's the 32 inches one.
The one... whichever one I did Doki bite on.
Um, the one that's 240 Hertz.
Uh, the one... anyway.
Um, so like, you know, I... I got the electric screwdriver.
It works guys!
The electric screwdriver works!
Uh...
So like, obviously my manager was trying to like teach me how to do it.
Because like, um, because I was like really confused.
And then he was like telling me like, oh yeah.
So like, a normal person would, you know, um, unscrew the PC arm.
The monitor arm.
And then put it on the ground.
And then you can use that to like, unscrew it.
So, you know.
That's what a normal person would do.
And I was like, I didn't do that.
I...
Uh...
Um...
I didn't do that.
Instead, what I did.
I held the monitor.
And then went...
I didn't want to also deal with a monitor arm.
So I...
I was like...
And then obviously I had to like hold it up too.
So that it won't like collapse.
And then, you know, um...
Held it up.
And then, you know, put it away.
And then I went to my bed and laid down for a sec.
Laid down for like 5 to 10 minutes.
And...
And then I laid down for like...
10 to 15 minutes.
More like.
For 10 to 15 minutes.
And then I unpacked my 32 inch monitor.
Um...
My 32 inch monitor.
And was like...
Alright!
Now time to unpack...
Open it for the first time.
And...
Uh...
Bring it over...
To the...
You know, PC mod...
Like the PC arm.
The monitor arm.
And then...
So, you know, I brought it over.
It was pretty fucking heavy.
Um...
And then...
And then I realized...
Oh!
That's what my manager meant when...
When he said...
A normal person...
Would...
Take...
The...
Monitor arm down.
And put it on the floor.
Because it'd be easier to put it on...
Hahahaha!
I was like...
Oh!
I see why...
He told me to do...
What a normal person would do.
And why it'd be easier.
Anyway!
So I didn't do that.
So instead...
I...
Put the monitor...
At my desk.
And then I went back to my bed.
And laid down for another 10 to 15 minutes.
Uh...
Hahahaha!
Also...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's my first time catching the stream.
Who is that?
Doki Amber Doge.
That's my dog.
He's a wiener dog.
I call...
I named it after myself.
Because I'm an egomaniac.
And so...
But it gets a little confusing.
When his name is also Doki.
So I call him Doki Amber Doge.
So in short form...
It's dad.
Anyway!
So...
Um...
Second break time is over.
So I like...
Obviously I had to hold up...
The monitor.
And then like...
You know...
Trying to align it.
Holding the monitor up.
By the way...
Vertically!
Hahahaha!
The monitor.
Because I couldn't...
Rotate the arm.
So that it was horizontal.
So...
Vertically!
Trying to hold up...
The 32 inches monitor.
Aligning it...
On the...
Screw area.
And then was like...
Struggling a little bit.
Because it was very heavy.
Hahahaha!
Vertically!
Trying to hold it against it.
And then like...
Okay, you know what?
I'll...
Do an art.
I'll like...
Draw it out too.
For you guys.
So you guys know how...
How silly I was.
Hahahaha!
And then...
Okay.
And then there's...
Me...
Being like...
Hahahaha!
And then...
And I also have to be here too.
And like...
Holding it as well.
Mia 1, Mia 2, and then these, okay, you'll know what I mean.
And then these are my two other monitors.
The size comparison.
Alright, anyway.
Alright, so I sketched it out and then... Alright, let me save this real quick so you guys can see.
Okay, it looks a little confusing because I draw both versions of it.
me in the same picture.
So, to be like... Alright, so I drew both versions of myself.
So, this is like... This is the monitor I'm holding.
So, this is the arm right here.
Like, um... Let me give you a mini cursor.
Um... I'll give you... Whoa!
Whoops, I dropped my controller.
I'm a little bit of a mess.
Alright.
I dropped that.
Alright, give me a sec.
Let me grab a...
Uh... Cursor for us.
Okay.
I'll use myself as a cursor.
Alright.
So... So... This is... This is... Right here is the monitor arm.
Right here.
So, you can see this area.
Where it's like... The screw... Like, we're at the screw it on.
So, this is me holding it up.
Um... Holding it up like this.
And... And then... And then... And then... Um... And then be like, Oh, shit!
I need to be on this other side.
So, that I moved over here.
I'm being like, Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Here.
And then... Holding the screwdriver gun.
And... Um... The screwdriver... Uh... Electric screwdriver gun.
And then, like, holding it up and being, like, AHHHHH!
Because all I needed was one screw.
All I needed was one screw to, like, to make it work.
So that took me, like, maybe, like, five to seven minutes to align that one screw into the hole.
And after that, I let go of my hands.
That might have been a little silly to do.
Maybe a little stupid to do.
Because, like, obviously, you don't know that one screw was gonna hold everything together.
But I was tired and I was willing to take the risk.
So, I was tired and I was willing to take that risk.
And so I let go after the one screw was screwed in.
And, um...
And then, um...
It worked, though.
It worked.
And I had to find, obviously, I was trying to find the second and the third.
So I let go of my arms.
I let go of my hands.
The moment that one screw was over.
Because I was like, oh, thank God, I don't have to carry the minor anymore.
I can't carry it anymore.
And then I was like, oh, thank God, it's over.
And then, and then, obviously, I had to, like, get...
I was trying to find the...
How the second screw to put it in and go...
And then the third, fourth.
And then it was done.
And then everything went okay.
A lot of things could have gone wrong.
But luckily, nothing did.
YOLO, am I right?
YOLO!
Um...
Juliano, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, Doki, today is my birthday.
Can I get a...
Can I get a happy birthday?
Of course you can!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Juliano.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Dark Ace, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Lord Kurosis, thank you for the super chat.
I feel like I speak for all dragoons when I say we're happy in the miracle that is you somehow We are now surviving this long occurrence.
Papa Smer, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Every day, Doki doesn't final destination herself is a miracle dragoos must give thanks for.
Hats and clogs, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I love these yaps, they make me feel like such a confident adult.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Hey guys, I saved money.
Instead of hiring a handyman, I was a sort of handy woman today, or not today, but like yesterday.
I was sort of handy.
My third monitor is up and running now.
Alan, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Alan, I don't believe in God, but knowing you're still alive, being in this shelter makes me believe in one.
And he loves you.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Look at that.
Look at that, guys.
I did it.
My third, I didn't have to pay extra.
I saved that money from hiring a handyman, so I can, so I can waste all of that at the hair salon.
Look at me go.
Oh, Johnny, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Now I know where all your luck went.
It went to surviving to real life incidents.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Grab my controller, I dropped it on the floor.
Grab it real quick.
Alright.
Anyway, so that was my life update for the last couple of days.
It's been pretty eventful.
Now we're back to Super Mario Man!
I don't know how long to play today.
Um, so we'll see how it goes.
Uh, no, don't say that.
Tokyo time!
Oh yeah, I forgot.
I have this fucker.
With me.
Okay, no!
Leave me!
Wait, how do I get out of here?
I don't... Oh my god, stupid.
Oh my god, I forgot he killed my entire team!
Hahaha!
I forgot!
I forgot this guy killed my entire team!
Okay, he has to come with me.
We need to heal.
Hahaha!
I almost forgot.
That singular jab, he almost killed the entire team.
Alright.
Let's go back.
Okay, we gotta heal.
Alright.
Hahaha!
Oh yeah, I forgot the Yoshi!
Okay, I already forgot the Yoshi.
He heals me.
Alright, back I'll go.
Uh, Mr. Man!
Welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Alright, now you leave me!
Be gone!
Be gone, Toad!
Yeah, that Jabby was fucking insane.
I might have to... Wait, actually, what...
What... What type is he?
That Jabby was crazy.
Okay.
Why is he in box 13?
Why...
Hahaha!
What was my plan for him in box 13?
I don't...
I don't even remember what the plan was.
Haha!
I... I don't even know.
I was like, what...
Why is he by himself?
Alright, summary.
Uh, grass and dark.
Okay, what's Jabby?
What are you?
Bug and fly.
Oh, unfortunate.
I already have a fly.
What was the other one that fucked me up?
There was one more guy that fucked me up.
Oh yeah, I remember now.
Private X?
What was my pla...
Hahaha!
Guys!
Oh!
What...
What does the X...
Oh!
Private...
I remember what Private X was.
I...
Hahaha!
I'm like rediscovering myself.
Uh, yeah, I remember.
Now, where's the other guy?
Where I was...
I left...
Oh yeah, this guy.
Alright, what's your...
What is your...
Grass and dark.
God, you...
This guy fucked me up too.
Hahaha!
This guy...
This guy fucked me up as well.
Hahaha!
Alright.
Cause I do have...
Grass and dark.
Alright, we're gonna put a...
We're gonna put a nudist into my party.
This guy was...
Alright.
Don't worry.
You don't have to be here.
I'll put you here by...
Now you live by yourself.
And then you go...
You go here.
Fuck you.
I took a loan for those Pokeballs.
Alright.
Let's see.
What is this?
Wait, what's this?
You're too...
Oh my god!
I have to bring you over?!
Over!
Audio, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Just wanna tell you...
Good luck.
We're all counting on you.
Alright.
I have to bring you over, apparently.
Okay.
Baby Koala!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Box Bouncer Doki.
Is this good enough to bribe...
To get into a private exit?
It's okay if not.
Also, it was fun watching you yesterday.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Glad you had so much fun!
Oh my god!
Speaking of Night Ring...
Um, I actually received my Night Ring...
My free Night Ring collector's box today.
Um, so like, they basically sent all the streamers who were participating...
LET ME IN FRONT!
Um, sorry.
Toad wanted to...
Toad wanted to have some fun.
Wait.
How is he gonna go in?
Uh, but yeah.
They gave me...
They sent over the collector's box and I got it today.
Do I have to...
Oh, okay.
And then...
And then I swap.
Alright.
And I go...
God, you're so useless.
I hate you.
Oh, what?
Wait.
Why?
What do I...
What is my purpose up here?
Okay.
What...
What was my purpose?
Don't...
Why did he have to be up here?
I don't know.
I guess I'll just...
Fuck it.
Alright.
I keep forward.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I couldn't catch last Mario mon stream.
But I watched the VOD.
I saw you moved me from exile box to the goon cave.
A humble fart like me doesn't deserve such luxurious.
Well...
You see, the reason why...
You know the reason why you got moved to the goon cave.
Is so that Gordon...
Wanted to sit on you, right?
Like...
You got...
Ch-ch-chosen.
Yeah.
How does that make you feel for...
That this was...
This became your purpose.
Wait, I can't even move this.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
This is a puzzle.
I guess I could just...
Swim over.
Whee.
Wait.
What can you do?
What?
What do you do?
What is your purpose in life?
Okay.
I'm...
I'm thinking.
I am thinking right now.
What?
Oh shit.
That's not what I want to do.
Alright.
I'll figure this out.
Don't make me...
Don't make me use that to sit on you.
Alright.
Let's see.
Can I smash those bricks?
Wait.
Can I?
Oh!
I didn't realize they were smashable.
I'm just being a little silly.
A toad?
Are you kidding me?
I mean...
Can you?
Okay.
But like...
Do I want to smash it?
Alright.
Uh...
I don't remember what they're weak against.
It's been so long.
Maybe sunny...
Snow?
Was the...
Womp weak against fire?
Or...
Water?
Or snow?
Guys, I...
I don't know.
I don't remember.
This is the worst part.
Because I'm playing as toad and he's so fucking weak.
I don't know.
Oh, weaker to ice?
Okay.
And then...
I don't know.
Carry him.
As...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Ask chat what something weird is called.
One guy answers.
Blames that guy for everything.
Typical dokey.
Okay, Mr. Gordon Freeman.
Don't pretend you're all innocent here.
I asked...
What is that cake fetish called?
Where a guy or a woman sits on a cake.
Like...
And you were one of the...
You're like...
Oh, I know what this is!
It's called...
You chose to answer that specific question.
Maybe...
Maybe you should tell me why you know that.
So is being informed about the internet a sin?
It's not just that.
It's what you're informed about.
You set yourself up.
You could have picked any other question to answer.
Simple minded.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Can you please name the next one you catch after me?
My standards are low.
So I don't care what it is.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, so now knowledge is a sin?
No, no, no.
It just depends on what the knowledge is.
Aura, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I smashed Hulk 1973.
Okay, that should kill him.
Yay!
Can someone named Jokey Bird spits on Marvel Rivals recommended me?
I told you guys, right?
Whenever like...
Cause like, streamer mode doesn't work on Overwatch anymore.
Unless you play...
Unless you win like...
I don't remember how many.
100 plus games or some shit.
Or was it 500?
I don't fucking remember.
It was like an obscene amount of games.
And then whenever they like...
Like, because it doesn't work anymore.
And then they'll be like...
Are you Jokey...
So it just says Jokey Bird?
And then they're like...
Are you Jokey Bird?
And of course I lie and say no.
Alright.
I'll just be like...
I'm just a fan of her.
Like...
And then they'll just be like...
Aw man.
I'm so stupid.
Asking this random person if they're a Jokey Bird fan.
Aw man.
What do they know?
That was me.
So if anyone ever asks you...
Are you Jokey Bird?
Just say...
No.
Because obviously, lying is a sin.
Unless you're me.
And I know I'm already going to hell.
So like...
One more lie doesn't hurt me.
Um...
What's...
One more lie.
What's gonna happen to me?
Anyway...
I'm going to go to...
The worst type of hell?
Um...
So true...
Pear...
Um...
She's well prepared.
Anyway...
You are forgiven...
Forgiven.
Eating, thank you for going to super hell.
It only takes one more lie for me to...
No, Toki!
You're one lie away from super hell, Toki!
Don't do it!
Anyway...
Eating, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Not the worst person to be recommended by.
Not so Deadpool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You should tell one person, yes, but no one will ever believe you.
Oh, so I do that thing the Ghostbuster guy does.
Where he, like, fucks with people and just tells them, like, does, like, ridiculous shit.
And then he'll be like, no one will ever believe you.
But the thing is, they can just screenshot that.
You know what's the difference between interaction on the internet versus interactions in real life?
You can't screenshot an IRL encounter.
Ah, yes, the Bill Murray...
The Bill Murray thing.
I can record you IRL.
That's just a photograph.
Um, Fudge, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, free my man.
He doesn't deserve to be known as the Cake Fighter.
Dragoons don't deserve to be degraded into their fetishes.
So, anyway, is there inflation in this game?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Ah, yes.
You caught him.
Oh, yes.
Oh, you're talking...
Oh, wait, what's this?
Hammer arm.
Also lower speed.
Okay, who do we...
What do we not need?
You know what?
Okay.
What weather do we not need, guys?
What is the weather that we not need?
For more information.
Look up Sonic inflation.
For the...
For Sonic's impact on...
The economics of gaming.
Rain?
Okay, we'll get rain out.
Jokey, no!
Uh...
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's from an episode of Super Mario Sunshine Let's Play where...
Who's they?
When they found the girl from the video on Craigslist.
Who is they?
Oh, Ice Hammer.
Wait, that's great.
Wait, I don't have to use...
Snowscape anymore.
I have Ice Hammer.
Yeah.
Alright.
Himself.
Haha.
That's what they all say.
Yay!
Oh my god!
How many moves do you know?
Now you have crab- You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's get rid of...
No...
Let's get rid of Ice Toss.
We'll just use Sunny Day for...
For...
I'll just grab...
It is a hap...
Yeah, I'm gonna get rid of Ice Toss.
Everything returns to crab.
Alright.
Nice.
All the hammers.
I'm keeping the Sunny Day for Dad.
He deserves it.
Bleh!
That's it?
Okay, I need to actually heal him though.
Alright.
Is it him?
Is it the green boy?
Oh, it's green boy.
Lord Kurosus!
Thank you in the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't believe Dragos are getting shamed for the fetishes.
Anyway, totally underrated.
But can I- I can't- But if I can't be renamed to a drag- Dragon or a dinosaur Mario Mon, At least put one in the goon-
Wait, who are you?
In the- In- In Mario Mon.
Who even are you?
Alright.
Oh, that's the captain's box.
Alright, give me a sec.
Let me rotate.
I need to see you- Alright.
I need to know which one are you.
Alright.
Let's see.
Are you the Goomba?
Are you the first one?
Oh.
There you are.
I see you.
You already got one!
You got Ipu!
Is his- Is his lips not enough?
Kurosus.
Are his lips not enough for you?
Ipu, how do you feel about this?
You worked so hard.
For him.
And then he- He is requesting another one.
He is requesting a different Dragoon.
Damn.
So greedy.
He has the biggest lips too.
Where's Cygoon?
Is Cygoon here?
Are you satisfied with your Dragoon?
Oh, just cause he's not a dragon or a dinosaur.
It's just not- It's just not enough.
I'm sorry.
Seems like- Seems like the customer wasn't satisfied, Ipu.
Don't worry.
You can- Don't worry.
I'm sorry, Oni.
I got to- You- You're being moved.
From the private X room.
You get to take a little break, Ipu.
There you go.
We need you.
You got- Called up.
Butchop.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I volunteer.
My lips may not be the biggest, but they'll be the juiciest.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
John.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I volunteer.
Just get me out of daycare, please.
In front of Mehdi like that?
What?
No, you guys have to keep making more eggs for me.
Manny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It was used up.
He belongs to the streets.
People, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There we go.
Alright.
Oh, I have to swap.
No!
It's time to make more kids.
Alright.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It was Green Grumps, Miss VTuber, Aaron.
That's it.
Oh, that resets it for me.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
And then we gotta go this way.
Okay.
And then...
Then I should be able to get across now.
Yay!
Alright.
Get that Skeeter out of here.
Yeah.
Jen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The next one you catch, I've volunteered to be named and thrown into the Goon Cave.
See?
See, Kurosis?
Why can't you be just like Jen?
They're willing to just be thrown into the cave?
They have no demands.
They just wanna enjoy themselves.
Alright.
They know what their job is!
Let's...
Let's beat up this monkey.
Alright, let's see.
You crush.
Sit on him.
Come on, watch.
Nice.
Thank God that's not...
Super effective.
Goodbye, monkey.
Yay!
Rock Blast.
It's not gonna do anything.
That's right.
I know some type advantages.
Only son.
Pop!
No.
You don't get anything in the exile.
You don't make any demands.
If you're in the exile box, you don't make any demands.
Baby, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's right.
There's no pleasure in the exile box.
I'm suddenly very glad.
I failed to get a mod named early on.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, let's get.
Over here.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Mom, I'm scared of the dragoons.
I want to go home.
That is your home.
You think you have... You think there is a place that exists beyond your box?
No, that is your home.
You live there forever now.
Alright, we're gonna kill Clubber.
No escape.
This is why... This is why... I think like... I think that's why more and more mons are resisting capture.
They know what goes on.
They all know now what goes on in that PC box.
They don't want to be part of it.
They don't... It used to be so easy to catch them.
When did it get so difficult?
They've heard the rumors.
Someone broke the NDA.
What's this?
Demony.
There's more damage if an ally fainted.
Nobody's gonna faint.
It's like they knew.
Wait, what video?
I took away all your phones.
You can't contact the outside world.
It's like Big Brother.
You don't know what's going on outside when you're in the box.
All you know is where you live.
Oh, so...
I have to send...
Oh, okay.
Wait, what?
I don't have...
Oh, I have to go on the other side.
Oh, man.
Okay.
So I have to send Toad down here.
Maybe?
Alright.
No, you just live there forever.
No one's leaving.
Oh, nice.
My TM.
You can never escape.
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
I guess like Toad has to come down here, right?
Because there's like nothing else to do here.
What the fuck do you do?
Doki, please.
Oh, Nii, thank you for super chat.
Thank you.
Doki, please let me out of the cave.
I can't move at all.
Well, you gotta thank Kurosis for that.
He requested you.
I remember.
This is what Kurosis wanted.
I skipped the part I did.
Solid, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Just remember.
Kurosis requested you.
Sorry, there's nothing I could do.
Please, I don't want to keep getting stick bugged.
Get me out of here.
Alright.
Oh, it's here.
Alright, I found it.
And then...
Toad has to come with me.
Okay.
Now push that.
Wee!
Wait.
Can I even get over on the other side?
No.
Wait a minute.
Why did I do that?
I can't even get to the other side.
Oh, wait.
Will I be able to move it if I do the hands?
No, I can't.
Oh!
I'm being silly.
I'm so silly.
Okay.
Puzzle's hard.
Guys, I can push the rock back.
Alright.
Nice.
Just being a little silly right now.
What does that go to?
What did I do to that rock?
Oh!
Okay, so that means I can go up this waterfall now, right?
No?
What the fuck did I do to that rock?
Yeah, but where does it block to?
Oh, one more boulder?
Is it this boulder?
Wait, what other boulder can I move?
Oh, is it this one?
Oh!
There it is.
I see.
I didn't even realize I had to move this boulder, too.
Alright, don't worry.
I got you.
Is that it?
Oh, there you go.
Nice.
Oops.
Oopsie.
Alright.
Baby, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Actually, I don't want to be a toad while I'm there.
Because Mario has...
Doki has the stronger mons.
Alright.
Well, he's already in his original position.
The Wadi Rage is never on!
If only you could stop this raging torrent!
Alright.
Smash!
Okay.
All I have to do is...
Push...
Down...
Right...
Oh, okay.
That's easy.
I figured it out.
Alright.
Push!
Push like you're pregnant!
Yeah!
Okay.
And then...
What?
That's a good motivation.
That's a saying!
That's a...
That's a Canadian saying.
Any Canadians out there that would like a vouch for me?
We say that a lot.
Benny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
At least I can say I'm not being passed around like the other goons.
I just can't bring...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And now we swim.
Yeah!
Wait, what?
Oh my god.
Stick bug.
God damn stick bug.
Baby!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And what's over here?
Okay.
Wait.
There's something over here.
Oh, is that the button?
Can I push that?
And then he'll be able to go over there?
Is that Laura of Exod is where we kicked out of the goon cave?
Or were we destined...
You guys are destined to banishment until you get requested.
To live your life, exile.
Don't worry.
You all sign an NDA.
And then let me...
Smash.
Pass.
Okay.
There's this girl.
There's something here.
Oh, it's a power herb.
Yes.
Everyone signs...
When you're in the cab, an NDA shows up.
The moment you get capped...
Okay.
So, like, the NDA shows up in, like, 0.1 seconds from being captured and the click.
So, the moment it clicks, you sign the contract.
Yeah.
When you accept it, you get caught.
Exactly.
What am I supposed to bring this?
Oh, it's all the way over here.
Okay.
Down.
I know how to do this.
Boop.
And then...
And here.
I mean, it's better than the alternatives, right, Smug?
Think of the super chat that you think.
Yeah.
Okay.
Where does this go?
What was that?
I don't remember where that one was.
Oh, my God.
Is it just all stick bug?
Is that how that is?
It's just stick bug.
I can't escape.
I close my eyes and I see him.
Stick bug.
Oh!
Oh, my God.
Okay.
We...
There's just a dinosaur.
Just a fucking dinosaur.
In my Mario game.
It's like...
It's not like it's like a special like Mario character or anything.
It's literally just a dinosaur.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Does anyone have like...
Okay.
My nudist.
My nude man.
Yeah.
I know he's from Odyssey.
Because like...
Dude, I remember...
Oh, my God.
There you go.
You took off your clothes already.
Okay.
You already...
You already took off your clothes.
Good for you.
Good...
Get in here.
Ha ha ha ha.
I want to be a T-Rex.
Don't keep...
Mr. Broken Bond.
Thank you for the Aka Super.
Thank you.
Johnny.
Thank you for the Super.
Goodbye.
My nude man.
If I can't.
Alright.
We're just going to slowly send in.
Mom's in there while we try to catch him.
Okay.
I'm scared of killing him.
Oh.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Thank God.
Oh.
No.
I swear to God.
You got tired?
You...
He got tired.
I...
How?
How did you get tired?
I...
Yes.
Thank you for the Super chat.
Thank you.
This Yoshi looks a little weird.
Yeah.
I know he's from honesty.
Because I remember in the trailer, like...
Mario, like...
Twix over his body.
And he has his mustache.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for the Super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for the Magenta super.
I volunteered to nightly trample the goons in the cave.
All right.
Nice.
Here.
How is this here?
Exactly!
That's what I'm saying!
How is he here?
How is this here?
Why is his head so fucking big compared to his body?
Oh my god.
He looks like those dogs with no necks.
You know some...
There's like a genetic defect.
Where some dogs are born without necks.
That's what he looks like right now.
Like, he looks like a necklace dinosaur.
What?
Have you seen that?
I thought those were photoshopped.
But there's like actual dogs born without necks.
It's so weird.
Steampunk.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I paid less money.
But it would be funny.
Does he got to have something to do about it?
Regardless, it's terrifying.
I want six...
I want a...
I want this necklace dinosaur in my...
What the fuck?
His miniature sprite looks so badass.
T-Rex easier.
It is ugly.
He's easier to catch than the fucking jabby.
Alright, broken bod.
Broken goon.
Broken...
Goon.
Alright.
I need...
Oh, wait.
No, you're not...
Don't...
Don't get...
Get him out of the...
Get him out of the goon cave.
Don't let Kurosu see him.
Don't...
Don't let...
Don't let Kurosu see him.
Wait, is Yoshi also a dragon type?
Oh, he's normal.
But...
I'm sorry.
Wait, you're not...
Wait, you're...
You're just gonna be naked forever?
I can't...
Come back when you put clothes on.
Come back when you put some clothes on, Kaz.
Come...
Please...
What a freak.
That's right.
Get out of the party until you wear some fucking clothes.
You don't stand a chance against my master strategy, Mario.
There's children here.
No, no, no.
If you're a kid watching my stream, you're not allowed to technically.
You're under 13.
Yes.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's a fashion statement.
You wouldn't get it.
I have become fully bald.
That's why you're back in the cave.
Actually, you should be in the goon cave.
I forgot if there's like rocks.
You know, I'm just gonna throw a magnet at him.
Of course.
Of course, Yugi's protect.
He just don't wanna get sad on.
You just reflect?
Oh, okay.
Just a little bit.
Yeah, I'll sit on him again.
All right.
Goodbye, bird.
Bye.
Yay.
Oh, he has like a custom music when he dies.
That's cute.
Lord Kurosis, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Is that nice?
He plays a...
He plays music for his death.
Oh, egg bomb.
Wait, that's good.
Throw your children, Yoshi.
Yoshi.
All right.
We'll get rid of headbutt.
It's time to throw your kids.
You stay away.
Don't let him near any of the dragons.
Okay, I'm gonna use the magnet bomb on him, too.
All right.
Bye.
Oh, it's super effective.
So happy.
Look at him.
Oh my god, he lives that?
Oh my god, how big is that moon?
Oh, it hits both of me?
What does he do?
Oh no, it doesn't.
It's just that it does himself.
Oh my god.
He's bigger than dad?
I can't believe it.
The moon is bigger than my dog.
Yay.
Bye.
How?
Wait, I want to do something real quick.
Where is he?
Since you're naked, you deserve to be in here.
All right.
No more dragon time for you.
You can...
Back to you, you're at the safety.
Oh, no, you're not.
Eagerly waiting for this.
All right.
One lucky guy.
You know what?
Hmm.
No, I don't think anyone deserves it yet.
I...
One lucky dragoon.
Oh, wait.
But what's over there?
There's something over here, though.
Wait, what?
I could have went this way this entire time?
Oh my god.
Toad could have been there this entire time.
Okay, I got healed.
I got healed of Doki real quick.
Okay.
I can't believe there was a random dinosaur.
Like in Mario Lord, the dinosaurs never went extinct.
The meteor never happened.
That's crazy.
That's actually a crazy thing to think about.
The meteor never happened.
What else didn't happen?
There's no way.
If the meteor happened, explain the T-Rex.
All right.
Let's go together.
We're at Banana Temple.
Hawaii!
Excellent work.
As always, your explosiveness.
Now nothing stands between us and the golden banana.
Come on.
We're going in.
Wait, the monkeys just let him in?
Sorry.
The gorillas just let him in?
Looks like this is it, Mario!
We better make sure we're prepared for it.
Before we take on Bowser.
I'm pretty sure we're prepared, right?
Yay!
I got an air balloon!
Not so Deadpool!
Thank you for the magenta soup!
Thank you!
How's not so good in this?
Ha ha!
DSL beauty!
Ha ha ha ha!
Wait, they're just going to let me in like that?
Please!
No, not the golden banana.
What do you mean you lost it?
I mean I lost it.
L-O-S-T.
Can't give you what I don't have.
No!
How do you lose an all powerful artifact?
It's your job to protect and watch over the golden.
The banana.
That's right.
That's what he get.
That's what they get.
Having a non-gorilla look after the banana.
I guess like the gorillas would have eaten the banana though.
I mean that is smart.
Never mind.
It is smart to not have a gorilla look after it.
So I decided to use it to clean my toilet.
I haven't seen it.
Never mind.
That wasn't smart.
Ha ha ha ha!
Comic.
Of course you're ruthless.
What?
Put me down.
What are you doing to me?
Ah!
Oh my god.
He killed the elderly.
What the fuck?
Go.
Search for the golden banana comp.
Did he just kill the elderly?
Sigh.
Of course, sire.
Bro.
You just threw him in the air.
About time you showed up, Mario.
You're just in time to witness the retrieval of the great golden banana.
Comic.
I found the golden banana, your rancidness.
Here.
Please take it off my closet, Eddie.
Ha ha ha.
Just like taking banana from a monkey.
Why is it wet?
Now and then.
Mario.
As I was saying, it's about time you showed up.
And he's joined by me.
Captain Toad.
Right.
I've been here the whole time.
What about me?
Nobody forgets Captain Toad.
Ha ha ha.
It's
the game in this entire world.
Let me think.
Ha ha ha.
Captain who?
That's silly.
Ha ha.
That's mean.
No, I agree.
Ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
Actual the plus one.
Oh, he's gone.
Ha ha.
I'm laying right here.
Ha ha ha.
Enough of this retrieval.
I already forgot.
If Captain Toad did not piss me off, I would also forget him.
Mero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I just realized the live action Mario movie from the 80s confirms dinosaurs are a thing in the Mario universe.
Yes, your potassium, this is.
It's time for a wild battle strategy.
Destroy Mario.
Mario, I have an idea.
Play along.
You're in for it now.
Comic, taught me about spread moves.
Wait, what the fuck is spread moves?
Wait, teach me too.
Ha ha ha.
Wait, also teach me what that means.
Oh, is that AOE attacks?
Why is comic like just as big as Bowser?
What the fuck is he?
Are they feeding him?
All right.
You know what to do, dad.
You only know one move.
And one move only.
Two versus one plus.
Use this fungus.
All right.
Oh, shit.
Oh, wait.
Nice.
Good job.
Good job, Toad.
Actual good move.
All right.
Thank God.
He actually used a good move.
I actually needed that.
All right.
Sandstorm.
Oh, my God.
He didn't fuck up.
Oh, okay.
Now they took away his fire.
I mean, it was nice using it for one move.
You know?
All right.
What else?
Spike top?
Oh!
Wait, he's upside down.
I'm going to squish him.
Nice!
Okay.
You have three other moves.
Hammer pro.
I mean, that's all right.
I mean, it works for me.
I'm them using fire.
It works for me anyway.
Just remember, you have three other moves.
K-pop.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
How dare you suggest it.
This movie is canon.
All right.
It's not very effective.
Oh, he sent himself.
But he doesn't wear a hat when he's himself.
Does he, like, take off his hat?
When he sends himself out?
Okay, nice.
He actually used a different...
I got a little worried.
I thought he was gonna, you know...
Oh, okay.
I thought he was, you know, still gonna use that one move.
Still gonna use Sunny Day.
Because I know they said, like...
Uh, Captain Toad is a little buggy.
Where he'll always spam weather moves.
Yeah, he put on his fighting hat.
A hat for every occasion.
All right.
Now it's 2v1.
Yeah, I got...
I got, like...
I won't say lazy.
I just, like...
I got really confused on how to, like...
Patch it.
Because you apparently have to patch the ROM file.
And then I got scared.
Because it wasn't one click.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Because I was like...
How do I move my save file over?
And then I got...
I got really confused.
And then I was like...
Not one click.
I not do.
Yeah, I didn't want my save file to get deleted.
Oh my god.
He sent himself already?
There's, like, two more.
Wait, he's fire, right?
I think Bowser's fire.
He has...
Okay, never mind.
He has to be fire.
He literally spits out fireballs.
What do you mean, go Bowser?
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
What the fuck do you mean?
Go Bowser.
Ha ha ha ha.
Oh, he's drag...
He's not even fire?
I thought he'd be fire type.
Because he's...
He literally spits out fire.
Okay.
Wait, Ice was...
Oh, I guess Ice is effective on...
Jesus Christ, he's so fucking tanky.
Okay, apparently he doesn't get critical hit.
I'll just sit.
Yeah.
Oh my god, it's not...
I knew it!
It's not effective at all!
Yeah.
Jesus, thank god I'm, like, ten levels ahead.
Alright, goodbye.
Oh, never mind.
I'll just use Crash Chop.
Nice, that's fine.
That's...
Yeah, I knew it.
That's fine.
It should be okay.
Yeah, because, like, he's also fire.
Chop!
Yeah!
I'm doing great.
Alright.
One last mod.
Who is he gonna send?
It can't be...
Oh yeah, there you go.
Mecha Koopa.
I was gonna say, it can't be that strong.
Because I literally...
Like, he literally, for some reason, sent out himself.
Like, second.
Yay!
I did it!
I'm the main character!
It's always year of the...
Like, year of Mario.
Mario.
Alright, Bowser.
Spread moves can also hit me, you know?
I don't even think they used a spread move.
Because I just kept killing them one by one.
Comic!
What kind of battling was that?
Your captors couldn't last more than two turns against Mario!
But, sire...
I don't want to hear it.
I want a full battle report on how you could have performed better.
Yeah, he didn't even use the spread move.
But, no matter.
With this golden banana, our teams can come back to full strength.
What?
Where is my golden banana?
Why, you little...
Ah!
You lost all your leverage, Bowser!
Give up!
I would listen to the mushroom if I were you.
It's Donkey Kong, and with his ass in Capiton's face!
The Kong!
The Kong Army!
I don't know how you can see past that.
The face full of cheek.
The dump truck Kong.
We would have come sooner, but we wanted to watch DK beat the one-up out of Luigi some more.
Oh my god!
Wait, what?
Poor fucking Luigi!
The bro of Donkey Kong was beating up Luigi?
We're getting some Smash Bros action already.
So that's where he's been.
Look, I think it's best for you to make like a couple of bananas and split!
Ha!
That's funny, I should write that down.
Kongs!
Ooh!
Yeah, yeah.
We get it.
We'll be seeing you again soon, Mario.
Ha ha ha ha!
Mario and Captain Toad, thank you so much for driving Bowser out of here and keeping the golden banana out of his grasp.
I'll be taking that back now.
Sabina, thank you to the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Your toad voice is amazing.
Thank you.
I just chatted on my...
Everyone has an inner toad.
I basically like use my March Simpson voice and just like scream it.
Ha ha ha ha!
Mmm!
Homie!
Ha ha ha!
I am your character, like, homie!
And then...
And then toad voice would be like...
Ah!
Homie!
Ha ha ha ha!
Now enough monkeying around!
Ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
You see what I did there?
We're monkeys.
So...
Monkeying around.
But we're actually not Kongs!
Ha ha ha!
Or apes!
Not monkeys!
Ha ha ha!
I cracked myself...
Oh my god, he's basically me!
I always make myself laugh!
Flyer!
I have a...
I have a weekly comedy night!
The quest, Monkeying Around, is now active.
The palace is now open for you to challenge Donkey Kong for the power star.
Be ready!
Ha ha ha!
I feel like I'm forgetting something.
Ah!
Eh!
Oh!
Wait, Donkey Kong can't speak Mushroomlish?
That's right!
You'll need this to climb the waterfall.
Oh, I got a jet attachment.
There's a river pat behind you that can take you back to the capital.
If you ask me, it's a great way to escape!
Ha ha ha!
Actually, apes and escape has the word ape in it.
Everyone's gonna love that one.
I'm on fire!
Donkey Kong is illiterate!
Ha ha ha!
Cheeky!
I think that's my best one so far.
Where am I?
I think it's time for me to head back on the toad town!
Don't look so sad!
Oh, what?
Do I look sad?
No, I'm crying tears of joy right now.
We'll see each other again.
No, no, no.
I hope I never see you.
If you die in a car crash, I will send flowers.
But not because I feel bad.
For another adventure!
Oh, and here's a little gift for me too!
Oh, all those captures?
You mean the one capture?
Recycle Bin.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Donkey Kong.
Oh, sorry.
I meant Mario Kart crash.
Don't worry.
Ha ha ha ha!
He's okay.
I meant Mario Kart crash, guys.
I think...
I think I've been dreaming of my party!
And bang, we better use to have them!
I said to the last box of your PC that I'm keeping my Hammer Pro and Power Glows!
Now get those Power Stars before Bowser and Luigi do!
Good luck, Mario!
Anyway, I'm looking forward for Garfield Kart 2.
I saw so many people at me.
Yeah, for Garfield Kart 2.
Everyone's like...
Oh, my God!
Jokey!
Ha ha ha ha!
Garp...
Wait, he's back!
What's that?
Come on, here safely.
But you don't get to be the guardian of the Golden Benet while earning such a position.
After I got launched by that Magi Koopa, I snuck back in and head out until everything blew over.
I also got to dodge Cranky Kong while I was at it.
I am the guardian of the Golden Banana.
Keeper of the ways of the WoW battle.
Would you like me to teach your captures a special move?
What's the fire pledge?
What's coaching?
What the fuck?
Oh, they're like...
Oh, they're like moves that he could teach.
Yeah, no.
That's fine.
I don't need those moves.
Alright, time to get stick bugged!
Ha ha ha!
You'll never escape stick bug.
Oh my god.
At this point, I might get a rappel just for these guys.
Wait, where am I...
Am I going the right way?
Wait, it's a scuttlebug.
Oh my god.
That's what they look like?
I've just seen the purple one.
So I don't...
I never realized what the actual...
What the other one looked like.
The color was.
Oh my...
I'm...
I'm putting on the rappel.
I can't...
I got scuttlebugged.
Is this it?
Wait, this is also another...
Hey Mario, it's me.
Okay, I'll take a photo.
Okay.
I actually don't know if I'm going the right way.
Whoa!
Mama!
I'm catching you.
Oh my god.
And your tongue is out?
You're perfect.
Perfect.
Does he don't lick too?
That's the Deadpool.
Thank you for the five gifted chips.
Thank you.
What's that tongue do?
I don't know.
But I know some goons who are going to look forward to that.
Who was it?
There was one.
I know there was a guy here that was like...
I have very low self-esteem.
So can I be named after something?
And I was like, okay.
Alright.
I'm trying to find it.
Where is it?
Where are you?
I'm trying to...
Oh my...
You're simple-minded?
Simple-minded!
If it's...
Exactly!
There you go.
I remember you, simple-minded.
Alright.
Let's get you in here.
Oh wait.
Now you can crunch?
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Whoa.
Oh, it takes two...
To three turns.
Yeah, we're not doing that.
I'm impatient.
Hobita, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Mama goes well with that.
Alright.
A two-legged salamander with an endless appetite.
It opens its mouth wide and charges towards its next dinner.
It's my best friend and perfect in every way.
Alright.
Let's see.
Simple goon.
Simple...
Goon.
Oh my god.
And it's female, too.
Alright.
Let's make sure he's in the...
She's in the right box.
Alright.
Waiting for...
I'm just lining them up.
Just waiting for their next customer.
Oh!
Maisie D!
Oh, it's this one!
This one's cute.
I like this one.
You just get to be in the private Xbox.
Oh.
Zzzz time.
Zzzz.
He's a-sleeping.
Oh, okay.
I got...
Okay, I actually got a...
Alright, you know what to do.
Hahaha.
Nyaoshi!
Alright.
This is like...
Guys, it's my weakest move.
Nyaoshi!
Okay.
Maybe I'll...
No, I pressed B.
I accidentally pressed B.
I...
I accidentally pressed B instead of A.
I'm so sad.
I wasted... Oh my god, no!
Don't tell me those are rare captures too!
Of course it is!
Of course it's a rare capture!
Oh my god!
No!
Of course you're a rare capture!
Of course I only fuck up when it's a rare one!
Oh my god, it was!
It was!
I'm so sad.
How do I always manage to do that to myself?
There's something else here too.
Oh my god, I found another one!
Oh thank god!
Okay.
I'm gonna try throwing a cap now.
Oh, is she really that strong?
Okay.
It's time to... Time to do it again, Dragoon!
Alright.
If you find it again... Hannah Clarks!
Thank you to the super chat!
Thank you!
Alright.
Oh yeah, Ryuki was like, can I please be the flower?
And then I ran away.
Alright.
Lick the flower.
Oh nice, it's paralyzed too.
Nice.
Can't move now.
That's right.
Break the... Break his shins!
Alright.
Now they're all asleep.
That's okay.
I can catch her now.
Or him.
Okay, never mind.
Apparently not.
You're paralyzed!
How are you still moving?
Okay.
Okay, there you go.
Are you serious?
I don't think I can do... I don't think I can lick the flower again.
Because he'll die.
Oh my god.
Oh goodbyes, Dragoon.
And then it's a crate.
Okay, I'll send... I'll send Hefley in here.
There's no way Hefley can die to this.
Hefley, there's no way.
Please.
The Mafia is after me.
Because I spent too much... Too much of my money on these caps.
Please.
I bought 99.
I... Why?
Oh no.
He knows about what I do in the PC.
He knows what happens in the PC box.
He knows.
I swear to god.
He's been moving this entire time.
I didn't realize being paralyzed was just like... Just a statement.
Jesus.
He's fighting.
Oh thank god.
There we go.
This flower doesn't want to sign my NDA.
Sign the NDA!
Sign this NDA you little flower.
That's right.
NDA sign.
Yay!
Alright.
Oh my god.
Everybody's leveling.
Jesus Christ.
How strong was this fucking flower?
A close relative of the crazy daisy.
Often confused for a shiny.
Its strength matches his elusiveness.
Somehow, a crazy daisy.
Crazy daisy can evolve into this.
Holy shit.
This has to be some fucking god flower.
Alright.
Okay.
Do we give it to... Roku or Hat, guys?
Who do we give it to?
We'll let chat decide.
Roku?
That's... Okay.
Hat.
Roku.
Combine the names.
There's R-O-R-O-K-K-K-K-U-H-A-T.
No.
I can't.
I can do Rock Hat.
You know what?
You're right.
You get to share.
It's sharing time.
Rock Hat.
Okay.
You're sharing custody.
You get to share custody of this flower.
Alright.
Someone said to check the stats for this guy.
Who gets the weekend?
You decide.
Jesus Christ!
What the fuck?
His special attack is 103?
Holy shit.
Alright.
Wait.
It's fairy, right?
I'm sorry, Rice.
You're a little useless.
But I'll put you in the goon cave.
I'm sorry.
Papa, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What an FMA Edward did I just do?
It's okay.
But you're... You look... You have a... You... You...
You... You look pretty.
Okay.
But like... But like... But like... Your moveset was not the best.
I'll have to admit.
But don't worry.
Don't worry.
I'll let you pick.
Would you like MAMA?
Would you like... Wait.
It's rice here?
Would you like... Simple?
Or would you like Ipu?
You get to have...
I don't know if Rice is here.
Because Rice was in my party, okay?
Anyone that gets to be in my party gets to pick.
They're heroes.
Oh, Rice is in here?
Alright, chat, who would you pick?
Um, you have to say it.
Thank you for your service, Rice.
Alright, I'll give it to Mama.
You didn't let me choose?
Smug, it's because you fucked up!
Rice didn't fuck up!
You fucked up!
I lost a mod in there!
Alright, we go this way.
Oh, alright, okay.
Rice, Rice, I see you.
Who do you pick?
Did you want Simple or Ippu?
Which one?
In fact, I'll let you pick.
We have so many choices.
We have Notsogoon, we have Delgoon, we have Wispgoon, Progoon, Yansgoon, and Kazgoon.
But not him.
This one's especially reserved to Gordongoon.
It's not him,
though.
Not him, though.
These two have to be together.
Those two are faded.
So many choices!
Not so technical!
Thank you for the super chat!
I know, it's so hard to pick.
We have a wide selection of goons here.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Gordon...
Gordon like...
Um...
Oh, okay.
There you go.
Congratulations, E Drag pixels.
You're back to...
You can go back to work now.
Gordon paid extra for this particular goon.
I really don't like your game, Toki.
It's not for me, it's for my dragoons, okay?
I'm- I'm just doing what I can to help my dragoons.
Running up business is very hard, okay?
I'm just- I have to wake dad up anyway.
He's gotta wake up.
I'm just gonna let the stick bug beat him up a little.
He does so little damage that he's, like, just poking him, and he's not waking up.
That's not waking up.
He just- oh, there you go.
Thank God.
I'm just a small business owner.
Trying to- trying so hard to make money for my- my little dragoons.
Giving my dragoons a safe place, you know?
A safe space.
I'm just a small business owner.
Alright, that's safe.
Don't worry.
Am I, like, go- I feel like I'm going the wrong way.
I'm just gonna see stick bug.
I have to have a repel.
There's no way.
Okay.
Uh, where's my pocket?
Do not have a singular repel?
I don't.
Wait.
Elevates the holder, and if hit, this item will burst.
Oh, the person will start- Oh!
Oh, I see.
Okay, I'm back on con capital.
Where does the right side go, then?
Oh, there's a gag.
Absolutely, thank you to the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We all float in the goon cave.
You'll float, too.
Thank you to the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad I conned up here before you challenged Donkey Kong.
I'm a little gizmo that can help you with understanding the cons.
Oh, I got a translator.
Thank God.
Finally.
I'm mighty surprised you were able to make your way through the kingdom with only context clues.
Oh, thank God.
Definitely don't need Toad anymore.
What's that now?
Captain Cold helped to interpret him for you?
Isn't that Captain Toad amazing?
Well, the translator is still yours so you can talk to him needing the captain's help.
Captain who now?
Say, I have another one for Luigi.
We won't have to know where he is so I can hand it off.
Luigi is with Bowser?
That's true in the air.
I hope he keeps himself safe.
I can't help but get a bad feeling about this while Bowser and Luigi's situation.
I think it's best to just focus on completing Cap Challenge.
And getting the Power Stars before Luigi.
He does.
Princess and I have been planning something for the first person to get all eight.
Alright, now have Luigi give Bowser his Power Stars.
Hold on to this translator for now.
Go get your fifth Power Star.
Alright.
Silly Luigi.
What is he doing?
Silly silly.
Alright, time to heal.
Zara, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Can I volunteer to be added to your...
No.
You gotta be chosen.
Or piss me off.
Is CrankyCon here?
Oh, wait.
Nice.
I get to watch the comedy show.
And now the moment you've been all waiting for.
Put your hands together.
For me, CrankyCon!
CrankyCon!
Woo!
Yeah!
Good evening, Con Capital!
I came out of a tree!
I love coming back to JAPES every week!
You guys!
My crowd!
My citizens!
My commucity!
Makes me happy to be a king!
I feel like they're forced to watch this.
Yeah, it's like a punishment or something.
Because he's the king.
You know, growing up, I was told I was going to be a poor king.
My father, the king before me, amazing con, said I wasn't fit to be one.
He always told me to stop monkeying around!
I was a piece of work.
I was such a piece of work.
You call me monkey business!
Please clap.
Please clap, everybody.
I couldn't stop.
Honestly, I thought I was better fit as a court jester.
And today, I'm not helpful not thinking about it.
This child was destined to be mine since birth.
My destiny was always predetermined.
I was so short-sighted to think.
How is it going to be your court jester every week of my life?
Cranky!
This is going to sound shocking.
But I don't want to be a king growing up.
I had three things on my mind when I was younger.
Upgrading my car.
Which banana I was going to have for dinner.
And taking off the car of my dreams.
Thinking you're out of her flummery boyfriend's life!
Please clap.
Hey, and will you know it?
Mario is here in my show!
Truth be told, I once wanted to take Mario out.
But I'm out of my life with arrows!
Let's give Mario a round of applause for being a great sport.
On occasion, he'll help us out.
But only when it's for his very special princess.
He's got it all figured out.
Oh, to think my life was all figured out.
Just by looking at the crowd, I can see most of you are in the process of figuring it out.
I see you in the front.
A banana martini in one hand.
You're a sweetie in the other.
And I can only assume you're jungling to pay off your card payments!
Ha ha!
Let me guess.
Loan from the casino kingdom?
Ha ha!
I see that guilty face!
You're probably also the type to do some gabbling here and there!
That's nothing to be ashamed of.
We all played a table of cards before.
Oh my god, how does he know?
If it was up to me, we'd be called Chip Pansies!
Ha ha ha!
God, I'm laughing my fucking ass off!
Well then, it looks like I've warmed you up for all my next two hours of my show!
Cranky!
Three hours of fantastic monkey jokes later.
Mario!
It says, Cranky's Comedy Hour.
When did it become Cranky's Comedy Hours?
Thank you again for coming to my show.
Thanks a lot for me to write all my material and perform in front of everyone.
Ha!
Not because I'm so talented and a king.
Oh, this comes natural.
Is that wild?
Just like wild battles!
Ha ha!
I told you it comes natural.
It was the texture to our free.
Encore!
Here's a little something for you.
Oh, I got a TM.
Nice.
Oh, I can't wait to be king so I can make you guys stay here for three hours.
More Dynasty Warriors.
Ha ha ha ha!
Respecting that flower?
If that's your wish, you're gonna have to take it from my monkey's paw!
Oh, I am good!
Come back anytime.
I perform literally every day.
All right.
Steven, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I can't believe what the dragoons are doing.
Anyways, on an unrelated note, as Lurker, I also like to be in that box.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
You can never escape the box.
See, I told you.
Everyone wants to be in that box.
Don't listen to the rumors.
Don't...
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Don't listen to the rumors!
Everyone's satisfied!
Oh, my God!
I...
We need another.
Steven, today's your lucky day.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha!
Don't listen!
There's no whistleblower here!
They're all liars!
Ha ha ha ha!
Steven, today's your lucky day!
Don't worry!
Be happy!
Who is it that...
Oh, there you go.
My shared custody goon.
Oh, my gosh!
She has, like, her own special song, too.
All right.
Sing!
You missed?
If you miss again, I'm putting you back in the box.
All right.
Ha ha ha ha!
I need this!
I need this, goon!
Oh!
It's time!
Ha ha ha ha!
I gave you one chance.
I gave you one chance to redeem yourself.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
All right.
They couldn't resist.
I'll give you one more chance.
I feel...
Today, I feel a little kind.
Oh, wait.
Actually, there's no way you'll kill him.
There's no way.
Okay, nice.
You didn't kill him.
Are you fucking kidding me?
And he wins!
Okay, you're going back to the box.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
I thought I could rely on you.
But clearly, I was wrong.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Clearly, I was wrong.
Back to the box, you go!
My old reliable dragoon who decided to get confused and hit yourself.
The power of two dragoons, and you still couldn't hit one sleep.
All right.
I'll give that goon...
I'll give those goons one more chance.
One more chance!
And then, after that, it's over.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Last chance!
Oh, nice!
Oh, that was fast!
What the fuck?
That was critical catch!
All right.
Nice!
All right, Steven.
Congratulations!
Steven.
Finn.
Oops.
Moon.
Nice!
Just fit.
Oh, wait!
Never mind.
St- Ha ha ha ha!
I spelled Steven wrong.
Uh!
Steve...
E-N...
Wait, it doesn't...
Okay.
Steve.
Sorry, but you are going to be called Q-goon.
Because it doesn't work.
Q-goon.
There you go.
Meep, thank you for the time to get the chest.
Thank you.
Oh, there you go.
Oh, you went to the goon cave yourself.
You knew where you were...
You knew where to go.
That's good to know.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Please.
Stuck me in the lockers.
It will make the straggler.
Solid Snake, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's true, I like boxes.
But maybe because it's in my jeans.
Greetings.
You must be Mario, no?
Are you ready to face Donkey Kong in the wild battle?
Yes.
Very well.
Please follow me.
Here we are.
Good luck, Mario.
Mario, what a surprise to see you swing by.
Haha.
Not like swinging out vines and tree branches.
Haha, you know?
You're right.
I'm just trying to be you cheeky.
Hahaha.
Please clap.
I knew you were all going to love that.
I had that plan for a while.
And using it with beta switch.
That's great.
I'm hilarious.
Here, have a flyer.
Catch me on my YouTube channel at Donkey Bird.
Donkey Kong gives you another flyer for his comedy night.
Anyway.
Ahem.
He's the leader of the bunch.
You know him well.
DK, DK.
DK.
Donkey Kong.
How does it go?
How does that laugh go?
Hahaha.
No.
Cheeks out.
DK starts flexing.
It expects which one.
Hahaha.
Wait.
What the cap is the banana?
Oh my god.
I think they're like grass-fed.
Are you serious?
I'm still gonna slash you.
He knows what he has.
Hahaha.
He's a little cheeky.
Look.
If he's got it.
He's gotta flex it.
You know.
Can't hide it.
Shouldn't hide what he's got.
Ooh.
I have a translator.
You're not even speaking proper monkey?
Hahaha.
Did they drop this?
Did they drop Donkey Kong from a tree?
It's like my translator's not even picking up anything.
Hahaha.
I don't understand.
Don't make fun of his accent.
He speaks his own language.
Bro, just.
Bro.
His accent is too sick for the translator.
Help me add in to protect.
Alright.
Oh, nice.
Oh, I'm glad they're all like, grass.
I'm still.
I'm gonna.
I'm gonna sit on that spike.
Hahaha.
Actually, I'm not sure.
But like, okay.
I knew he was gonna use.
Dude, did they all have protect or some shit?
Poor dad.
Crush.
Nice.
Poor dad.
Alright.
What is it?
Oh, it's the wiggler.
DK pounds his chest.
Okay.
Let's get rid of Trunkle.
Wait.
What did he use?
What does the Coba Berry do?
We can.
Oh, it weakened.
Okay.
That's good.
Crush.
Yeah.
I figured he'd be fighting too.
Instead of grass.
Alright.
Nice.
We have.
I think that's the last.
Last one, right?
Yeah.
That's the last one.
Goodbye, wiggler.
Bye!
That's right.
I'm not letting you change.
Yay!
Okay, I have to do.
What is this?
Not a hitting move?
Get out of here.
I only do damage.
Ooh.
DK!
Donkey Kong has lost!
Now.
Donkey Kong.
What did I tell you about throwing yourself into battle?
That's right.
Only losers do that.
Well.
As much as I hate to admit it.
Donkey Kong.
And by extension.
The Kongs.
Have lost above the Mario butters.
Luigi won?!
How did he win?!
I thought Donkey Kong was beating his shit out of him!
With his hands!
I believe this belongs to you.
How did...
Did he...
Did he just like beat him up after he won?!
The year of the Luigi never ends.
What if like Luigi won the battle and then Donkey Kong was like...
And then he just punched him.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
That seems like a Donkey Kong thing to do.
Oh I also have something from your toad friend.
Tell me to give it to you once you've got your Pyre star...
Oh I got the Pyre star?
Thank fucking God.
He sure gave it to me in the first place.
And don't forget this.
The Luigi is back, guys!
For the Nintendo Switch 2!
The Power Gloves should let you move boaters of ease.
Wait, that gives me an idea.
What do you got, Pumler, struggling to clog toilet?
Heavy duty!
Come by Jay Apes to see my show!
Ooh!
Okay, nice.
I did it.
Or I can just go back to the warp pipe.
Nailed it.
Yes, heal my mons.
At least like... Well, of course they're laughing!
He's literally the king!
If they don't laugh, he'll fucking execute them.
There's enough... There's enough cons to replace them.
Alright.
Before you go, I should let you know that a warp pipe isn't working properly.
Instead of going to the Metro Kingdom, it's currently going to the Sand Kingdom!
I have some other plumbers coming over to fix it!
Because today I know you're busy in the cap challenge!
You can still get to the Metro Kingdom by passing through the Sand Kingdom!
But you have to cross the desert first!
Good luck!
Oh no!
Wait, what?
Why is it a Team Rocket soundtrack there?
Use the plumber that's been giving the boss...
I forgot to spend my money!
It's time to pay up!
Yeah!
A thousand purple coins!
Or...
We'll take that gold!
Take...
No!
I'm sorry!
Please!
Don't break my knees!
I'm so sorry!
No!
Then it seems we're going to have to do this the hard way!
Oh!
I could just battle them?
That's easy!
That...
That should be easy, right?
Oh!
Wait!
What the fuck?
Why did you guys tell me I could just fight them?
Wait!
I was scared!
Oh wait!
That guy's water!
Wait!
Why was I scared for?
What?
Hahaha!
That's right!
They're level 33?!
Bah!
That's right!
What you gonna do now?
Okay!
I was expecting to have like...
A mon that was like level 99 or something!
That's right!
I'll rob the mafia then!
Wait!
What the fuck?
Oh shit!
Don't...
Oh my god!
All of them are like...
What?
Don't deny that a good time!
Damn!
I know!
They're like loan sharks!
They're from the mafia!
You expect them to buy better mons!
Yeah!
They should have made them like level 99!
I can't believe I was scared!
I can't believe I started spending my own money!
Alright!
Nice!
My sick bug grew another level!
No!
No detect!
It's strolling!
Alright!
I'll just keep...
I'll just keep like...
Actually...
Is rock...
No!
Rock doesn't do well!
I'll just use magnet bomb!
Ah!
I'll just fly!
Fuck it!
Just fly up!
Don't get hurt!
Don't get hit!
Hefty!
It's just one simple goal!
Don't get hit!
Yeah!
The casino is selling mons!
That's what I was thinking too!
You think like they...
They'd have better mons!
They literally...
They're literally selling them!
Yay!
The boss ain't gonna like this!
That's right!
You give me money!
What?
I get a thousand?
What the...
You try to steal ten thousand from me?
And all I get is a thousand?
Oh!
What do we do now?
You idiot!
You don't!
We bail!
Never tell the boss any of this!
That's right!
Run!
It's a me!
Mario!
Oh shit!
Wait!
It's what?
Are they plumbers now?
Where's the leak, ma'am?
Oh hey!
There they are!
The Cockaracha!
What is it called?
Ah!
Oh!
I got saucy sand.
The cockroach song!
The cooca...
Oh!
I love that song!
When are they ever gonna fix that word pipe?
Oh my god, he's so cute!
I just... I think I found out recently about that, that Cucaracha was cockroach.
But it's so catchy.
He's so cute!
The skelly guy!
What's this song about?
Just cockroaches?
What even... wait, what is that song about anyway?
Yeah, Cucaracha is like... it's like cockroach.
Yeah, it sounds cute until you realize it's...
It's just cockroach?
Wait, what?
The cockroach keeps dancing while losing legs?
What the fuck?
Wait...
The cow... but it sounds so happy!
They're like...
Le-ca-ca-da-cha!
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da!
Yeah, and it's like...
Please, this cockroach can't move!
His legs are gone!
A-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
Because it's out.
What's this?
I cannot walk!
He says...
Yippee!
He can't walk!
It's like London Bridge is falling down.
It's like... like children keep saying it's like...
London Bridge is falling down.
Falling down.
But it's literally documenting that bridge actually falling down.
That caused a lot of deaths.
And then children are like, Yay!
Let's make a nursery rhyme about this!
Yeah!
My fit lady, ring around the pos...
Oh, is it?
Yeah, was it ring around the posy about death as well?
Ashes, ashes, we all fall down.
Yeah, the ring around the rosy is about the play.
How did it go again?
I don't remember.
It's been so long.
Matt, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I would like to be named after a mom for no particular reason at all.
Thank you to the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Francisco, thank you to the super chat.
There's many... Oh yeah, I already read that one.
Yay!
Flown away!
Any wild... Oh, it's a wild... Oh, it's in here.
Okay, it's in this area.
There's so many... There's so many long goons.
It no longer work.
I actually don't know how to pronounce it.
I just remembered the cockroach part.
But Gus, thank you to the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Because she's lacking the two hind legs.
Jesus.
I already got all of them.
I don't...
How do I have all these mines already?
I don't think... I don't think this is a stretch of the desert.
This desert is too big.
It shouldn't be much longer to arrive in Tostarina.
Yeah, Tostarina.
Nice.
Oh, super rappel.
Okay, let's see.
Have I got all the mons for this area?
Count how much Xander is, grunt.
That's your first mission.
Okay.
One, two, three.
Why would you make him do that?
Four, five, six.
It passes time.
Oh, that's something I do.
It's gonna take so long.
Six, seven, eight, nine, Koopa Patrol.
Ten, eleven.
It's going to be so annoying.
I'm curious what the biggest number is.
Twelve, eighteen, fourteen, six.
Oh my god, he keeps...
How long does this go?
There are only 30 million sand particles in this desert.
See?
That was easy.
Oh, my stars.
I love that.
Oh, is that a reference?
To a...
Oh, to a Sonic...
Uh, the Super Snap Cube?
Never heard of that one.
Hey, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You see us Mexicans likes to enjoy...
likes to take the joy.
Uh...
What's this over here?
It takes the joy and the tragedy of the area of things.
It helps discover the iron things that seem too dark.
Traversing a desert?
It really takes a ton on the body.
Lucky to get into...
Tostarina.
Gotta have a little bit of an accent there.
I hope that's actually how it's pronounced.
Nostee!
Crush him.
Alright.
Yay!
How old is Snap Cube anyway?
How old is that?
Yeah.
How long ago was that?
Yay!
Go high!
Oh, he was like guarding it.
Oh, it wasn't even that old.
I thought it was like, old old.
Oh, it's a bully!
Alright.
Let's get him in here.
Uh...
The only thing I can do is lick it.
That's like, literally my shittiest move.
Everybody else can like...
Everything else can like, almost kill him.
Actually, I'll try Egg Bomb.
Oh, it's not very effective.
Okay.
Uh...
I'll lick it then.
Okay, yeah, that's...
Oh, that's okay.
It's planned.
It's okay, guys.
It was planned.
I'm gonna put Heffely in here.
Alright.
That should be fine.
Alright, get into this baseball cap.
Yay!
He knows...
Oh, he...
He doesn't know.
He signed the NDA not knowing.
He didn't listen to his friends.
A living spear of metal.
In groups, they assert dominance by shoving one another.
It's often hunted for its shell made of rare metals.
All right.
Matt.
Matt Goon.
Uh...
Smug!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It depends.
What does it mean?
I've been a streamer for too long to not randomly say things in another language when I don't know what it means.
Don't worry about it.
All right.
I'm never saying it.
Wait, what are you doing back there?
Okay.
Who do you excited?
No!
I want me to say it.
You gotta give me a better bribe.
Okay, I already have all of these guys.
I'm missing like one, right?
Oh, I'm in Toast Arena.
Hey there.
Did you come from Toe Town?
Sorry about the warp pipe not working properly.
We've run into some issues and could really use the help.
There's toads here too?
All the tourists bound for Metro Kingdom are getting a little antsy about being blocked in.
No, not the tourists.
And lastly, we have Kamek trying to freeze.
The entire desert.
Get that one away from Kamek, please.
I was gonna say.
I cannot.
There's like regular toads here.
Oh, it's a photo.
All right.
Nice.
This is what it was meant to snatch.
That doesn't look very important.
What's that?
What am I doing in this corner?
Nothing.
Now scram.
Welcome to Toast Arena.
We're a bit out of a small town.
I realize a rest stop is quite important.
We get all sorts of folks coming and going.
The kid over there likes playing heroes with us.
Who am I saying no?
Even gave us rocks, glutes, and nuts.
Wait.
Are these all children?
Don't tell them I can talk.
All right, local heroes.
Let's use our powers for good.
Smash, smash, smash.
Sometimes I'll play along in kids' games.
And he's getting out of work.
Oh, there's children here.
May he come back save months from now?
Okay.
I can't go here.
What does he say?
Oh, I already talked to him.
Okay, so this is 6-2.
All right, I'm in Toast Arena.
Oh, you're mighty, aren't you?
Can you tell this child man to calm down?
Maybe I'll listen to a hero like you.
Oh my god, I'm famous?
Oh my god.
I'm famous and they still make me pay for things?
I'm a hero.
The cap challenge.
I hope I can participate.
Can I, can I, can I, can I?
I should get free caps.
Isn't Toast Arena desert amazing?
There's so much history to explore here.
Welcome to Toast Arena.
Sorry, oh wait.
Through the painting in the tower.
Oh, I can just jump into...
Oh, it's like Super Mario.
64, I can just jump into the painting.
Oh dear.
Where did I put my umbrella?
Did I forget it somewhere?
Hello there.
Sorry I didn't hear you come in.
I was busy searching for my umbrella.
Is that a quest book?
Then you're accepting people's trouble then, correct?
Do you think you can help me find my umbrella?
As I remember it, I was out for a nice stroll near the front of town.
Okay.
Don't worry.
It means I will not do this quest.
I'm almost to the tower.
I need to get to Metro Kingdom as fast as possible.
What's over here?
Oh, it's another...
Oh, it's just an extra item.
All right, here we go.
Yay, a big nugget!
I can't believe I was worried about those loan sharks.
Wow!
This desert sure is fast!
I'm so silly.
I can't believe it.
I didn't even want to go to the Mario Kingdom in the first place.
And now I'm stuck in the desert.
Don't worry.
The desert will figure something out.
What's going to happen to our trip to Metro Kingdom?
Mario, is that you?
Thank goodness I tripped the same.
Oh, yeah.
They're talking about tourism.
It reminded me of the live-action Lilo and Stitch movie.
And, like, at first the audience review was really, really good.
But the creators review was, like, not good.
So people were like, what the fuck?
And then it was so funny.
So, like, spoiler alert for the ending of the live-action Lilo and Stitch movie.
But, like, Nani gave up Lilo to foster care.
So she could pursue a university degree outside of Hawaii.
I was like, what?
What happened to Ohana?
Yeah!
I was like, is that Ohana?
Ohana?
And then...
Yes!
Nani, like, abandoned Lilo with her, with her, like, quote-unquote boyfriend.
But they're not even, like...
Marine biology, by the way.
She wants to study marine biology outside of Hawaii.
An island surrounded by the marine.
Ohana means college!
So then she, like...
She, like, gave up her sister to, like...
Like, her neighbor and her, like...
She doesn't even get with the guy, too.
You know, like, what's his name?
David, right?
I forgot his name.
Because he's, like, usually he's just, like, Nani's plus one.
But, like, they don't even get together.
But she, like, gave up Lilo to, like, the neighbor and David.
But they don't even get together in the end.
And then, like...
And then there's a scene in there where, like...
You know how, like, Lilo...
Okay, they showed a comparison.
But, like, Nani tries to get rid of Stitch.
And then Lilo was like, That's not what that meant!
Ohana means family!
And no one gets left behind!
And Nani was like, You're right.
You're right, Lilo.
I hate it when you use dad's words against me.
And then in the live action...
Like, they made it so that Nani was like...
Was like, This is the real world!
This is reality!
Our family left us!
But then, like, if you know the story of Lilo and Stitch...
Their family...
Their parents literally died in a car crash.
So it's like...
What do you mean your family left you?
They're...
Like, what?
Like...
Yeah, they're...
It's like, Welcome to the real world!
This is reality!
Like...
Like, what the fuck?
They don't even talk about Hano!
You think they picked to leave you?
I'm like...
Ohana got lost in translation in the real world!
Mr. My...
Oh, it's Toads Rift!
Were you also tempted to go to the Mario Kingdom?
I was given the duty of bringing this group of Toads there as well!
I don't see if we found ourselves stuck here!
What's worse?
Sorry, a group has gotten lost in the desert!
Master Mario!
I wish to ask for your help in this matter!
I don't feel much tested in order to ensure you're prepared for the harsh desert!
Yeah...
Yeah, they like...
Yeah, it's so weird!
And then for...
And then like the...
The live action of the Stitch movie ended up getting like...
Good audience review!
And I was like...
What?
By the way, this is a different topic!
But like...
This is related because like...
I'm thinking about like reviews and stuff!
But you know how like...
In the Oscars...
People who vote in the Oscars...
Like the nominees and then which movie wins...
They don't have to watch any of the movies!
It's not a requirement!
But they recently made it a requirement that you have to watch the movies!
But then like...
They're now saying that...
Now like some of the Oscar voters are like...
Oh yeah, there's like a pro...
We have to like...
We could just leave the program running as if we're watching the movie!
So they would just leave the program running on the side if it's a movie that they don't want to watch!
And I'm like...
Why are you in the committee?!
Leave the committee if you don't want to watch the movie!
But the thing is...
You know, like the publisher... what is it called?
The book awards?
There's like a similar thing for books.
But it is a requirement that you read all the books to vote in the... I forgot what it's called.
It's like there's a book equivalent of the Oscars.
The Pulitzers, yeah.
For the Pulitzers, people who are in the Pulitzers Committee, they have to read every book that gets nominated.
And like, they actually have to or they're kicked out of the committee.
So like, people are like, okay, so like, there are people that are willing to read all of the books.
But like, in the Oscars, people don't want to watch a movie?
Is it really harder to watch movies?
It's because you don't get... yeah, no, Nexi, you're so right.
It's because like, who would want to... book author... book writers don't have enough money to bribe the book voters.
Like, think about it.
Unless your book becomes a multi-million dollar cinematic universe.
You don't have the money to bribe the book voters.
Like...
Um...
Let's see.
Uh...
Lord Crow says, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, Doki, can I reserve a spot for Johnny as the next Mario mod?
You catch it?
Here's the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'll try to remember it.
Kuma, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thanks, Doki, you convinced me to not go watch the movie.
You know, I never planned to in the first place.
I just thought it was fucked up.
That like, Ohana just disappeared.
Like...
Oh...
Like, like the whole message with the movie was about family.
And then Nani just...
Like...
Nani fucking abandons Lilo to pursue marine biology.
Like, what the fuck?
Ohana in this economy?
Oh yeah, then they made Jumba.
I like how someone said Jabba.
But they made Jumba into a villain and got rid of his accent.
Now he's just American.
He made Jumba sound so fucking weird.
Now he just sounds like an American.
And then he like, they made him the villain.
Yeah, he has no accent.
Wait.
Oh my god.
Wait, okay.
After this battle, let me see if I can find a clip of his accent.
Because even I was like, what the fuck?
Yeah, but they made him a villain.
Huff and Puff.
Oh, he's a big boy.
Uh, Gordon would want...
Oh man, Gordon would want him.
In the game.
Yay!
I'm like, almost there.
For Dragoon, for Yoshi to level up.
To evolve.
No, Gantu isn't in the movie.
Because it was too expensive to animate another CGI shark.
It's just too expensive, guys.
You don't understand.
Oh my god.
Wait, what?
No!
Don't hit yourself!
Why are you so stupid?
No!
Dad tripped and fell!
Alright.
It's not very effective.
Oh, that's fine.
Never mind.
It's not fine.
I'm gonna be like, that's fine.
I can just like, hit him again.
No, don't do it, Doki.
I know it's calling for you.
But don't do it.
Wait, what level is this guy?
44.
Okay.
I'll send it heavily.
Look, they're about saving money.
Also, I found out that Hollywood companies would purposely make movies, not earn enough...
like, make movies, like, not be box office and say they lost money on purpose.
Um, just so like...
Just so they don't have to pay the actors.
Because apparently, Goblet of Fire was a box office fail.
Which is crazy, right?
You know what they do?
They do...
They do a thing where...
I found out that, uh, they did a thing where they would pretend to loan...
They would set up a shell company.
And loan the...
Loan themselves an obscene amount of money.
And pretend that it was, like, a different company.
Um, just...
Oh my god, Hefley.
I'm sorry.
I was talking about Hollywood.
And, like, pretend that, like, it's, like, a different company.
And then they would, like, be like, okay, so we borrowed a hundred thousand dollars...
From the shell company to make your movie.
And their interest rate is, like, eighty percent.
Like, that's what they do.
Isn't that fucking crazy?
Just so, like...
Just so they don't have to pay actors.
And, like, direct...
Like, actors and writers and stuff.
More money.
Because, like, in their contracts.
Some actors in their contracts have it.
That were, um...
It's a percentage of what the movie makes in the end.
Yeah, it's a fucking T-Rex.
In Mario lore, the meteor never happened.
It's, like, revenue share.
I thought it was crazy.
That Goblet of Fire was not...
Was a box office fail.
Or, like, didn't make...
Didn't make enough money.
They, like...
They were like, yeah.
It never made enough money.
Like, what?
That's a multi-million dollar franchise.
What do you mean?
There's a lot of people obsessed with that shit.
Excellent job, as always, Master Mario.
I apologize for testing you.
But I felt it necessary.
Now then, about the Lost Toad.
Okay, I gotta get Lost Toad.
I marked down their likely location in your quest book.
I hope you're able to deliver them safely.
Alright, let me save this.
I need to show you guys Jumbo.
Guys, I need to show you guys Jumbo's voice.
It's actually, like, very important.
So, it is very important in this series.
Jumbo, live action.
I need you to know what he sounds like.
Alright, here we go.
Wait, let's see.
Okay.
I need to make sure I don't have...
Alright, there's one random guy with one like.
It's just gonna be like, who the fuck linked this?
This guy has...
By the way, this guy has only one like on this tweet.
But I just like, I...
It's like...
I just found it.
But...
It's just gonna be like, where did all these likes come from?
Like...
It's just gonna be so confused.
Like, where did all these likes come from?
What the fuck?
Like...
But...
But here we go.
Now you can hear what Jumbo sounds like.
Is that crazy?
Yeah, I know, right?
What the fuck?
What is this voice?
I know!
I'm like, what the fuck?
Why does he sound like that?
That's so silly.
Yeah, I know.
He just sounds like...
I don't know how to explain it.
He just...
As I said, he sounds American.
Sounds like a regular guy in America.
Oh my god, the Ultra Nut.
Let's go.
A food full of fat that restores...
You want Nut, Super Nut, or an Ultra Nut?
Let me get Repel, just in case.
Oh no, I don't need to buy any caps yet.
Look at how...
I'm like, rich in caps.
Look.
Wait, when did I have 35?
Wait a minute.
I had 99.
When did that happen, guys?
That's so...
When did I lose my 99 caps?
When did I remember the mosquito?
Hey there.
Come on in.
We got a rest stop up inside for a strange tourist.
Okay, we knew.
Where did all my caps go?
Where did it all go?
All right.
Yay.
At least I don't know if it's...
I'm so loud.
You can track our trail.
Flop my style, but it's not for sale.
Gold across my smile while I count my scales.
I've been on my mind.
Get from out of my trails.
Oh my god.
Lin-Manuel.
Rip the cord with no parachute.
We up in the core and we prepare to shoot.
Rigor mortis, you scared to move.
Our spear enormous, we can never lose.
That's it, bro.
Lock in.
Oh my god.
The hottest track just dropped.
Listen to my maracas.
They go like, Sha-sha-sha.
Sha-sha-sha-sha-sha.
Yeah, this is why I don't talk to the people in the Pokemon Center.
This is why I don't talk to them there.
Sha-sha-sha.
Uh...
Am I only missing one mod in the desert, guys?
Because if we are, I'm just...
Because...
Or am I not...
Or did I cut all of them?
There's no one to be sure.
Welcome to the harsh desert.
And got some competition.
Because of...
Oh my god, it's this guy!
Blarg.
Blarg!
Wait, that's his name?
Blarg?
Blarg!
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
Oh shit, he's made of lava.
Who woulda thought...
Ha- I don't know why I thought he wasn't made of fire.
Blarg!
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
I don't know why.
I just somehow thought he was just...
Not fire-like.
He does look like a Blarg.
Yeah, he does.
Oh, nice.
I wonder, like, this guy only has one Mon.
I mean, all he needs is a Blarg.
Jesus.
Yay!
Go, Dad!
Go!
Harsh, indeed.
Alright.
Oh, there's one of the missing toads.
Wait, no.
That's not a tourist.
Hey!
Aren't you Mario?
That's me!
Tokyo!
Don't worry.
Dad always wins.
The house always wins!
Crush him!
Yeah!
The first one's free!
You know what sucks?
Because the audience reviews were really...
Okay.
The Lilo and Stitch movie...
Live...
Okay, you guys want to feel sad?
The Lilo and Stitch live-action movie is a box office success.
It made more...
It doesn't take into account of inflation...
But it made more money than the original Lilo and Stitch movie.
Just so you know.
But they didn't take into account of inflation, though.
That's a good thing.
We're watching these.
Parents with children.
And also popcorn buckets.
Also, I didn't realize...
When the fuck did popcorn buckets became a thing?
Like...
When was that a thing?
Hold on!
Careful!
Some of the sound ahead is quicksand!
I'll suck right you into the cave below.
You see that tower behind me?
Nothing from bad vibes from it...
No, it has to be like a thing recently.
I feel like...
Like...
I meant like...
Like the special popcorn buckets that they do themed around movies.
Because I'm like...
When was that a thing?
I've never seen them before until like...
A couple...
Like a year or two ago.
Like usually the popcorn buckets...
Like the themed special ones.
You know what I mean?
Like the themed ones that match the movie.
Are you trying to get to Mushroom Kingdom or Metro Kingdom?
In that case...
You get through the Tostadina Tower!
Good luck!
You plan on scaling it!
Okay, we're gonna find the lost toads first.
I didn't realize they've been around forever.
I swear like...
Only recently I saw them.
Because of the dune one.
Yeah, the dune popcorn bucket was the first time I've heard about...
These special themed ones.
Absolute!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I haven't trusted Ryan who made us since they froze the audience score for Rise of the Skywalker at...
Um...
Eighty-six percent.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, get me into that...
Get me in the quick stand!
Nice.
The forbidden bucket.
Oh, there you go.
Why are you?
Why are you here?
So has Rise been looking for me?
Thanks, Mario!
I'll get back right now!
Nice.
We found one.
I wanna make sure we find all the lost toads.
There's some crazy ones out there.
Oh, yeah.
By the way, you know what I found out?
Okay, since we're talking about Lil and Stitch movies...
The original animated Lil and Stitch movie was made on a budget.
It's hard to...
It's really hard to think that because like...
Disney was like, we need a cheap movie to animate.
And that's how Lil and Stitch movie came to be.
Because it all takes place in one location.
That's just nature and not in a city.
So they're like...
Oh, that's cheap to make.
So I thought that was like such a cool...
I...
It doesn't even...
I was like...
That was cheap?
That is safe for Lion King too.
In Lion King, they reused a lot of assets from older animated films.
Because they were like...
Man, we can't...
We can't keep making expensive animated movies.
We gotta make something cheap.
So then they made Lion King and Lil and Stitch.
I thought that was like a fun fact.
We need this.
The missing link in the K in the Goon K.
The missing link.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I blame the Dune popcorn bucket.
Also Pop put on the maid outfit.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Benji, thank you for the super chat.
I've heard the live action remake has won the highest opening...
Yeah, it did.
The Lil and Stitch live action has the highest opening memorial.
Memorial Day weekend box office... Like, what was the competition?
I'm like thinking, what was the competition they have?
There's no way.
They must have had zero competition.
Nothing.
Like, what else was there to watch other than Leo and Stitch?
I guess there was nothing for the children, I guess.
You know, like Memorial Day for the kids?
Yeah, I mean, like, you will not... Oh, there it is!
Ironcliff!
You won't take your children to watch Mission Impossible.
Yeah, but the How to Train Your Dragon live action is literally like... Like, they showed like trailers and clips of it.
And it looked like... It looked like just a recreation of the animated movie, but worse.
Oh my god, I'm scared of Disney adults.
I'm not a Disney adult.
I like... I like Disney songs, but I'm like... I'm not a Disney adult, but like, I'm a little scared of them.
You know, you heard about the Disney... The VIP Disney Club, where like, some people waited eight plus years...
To... On the waiting list... To like...
Um...
On the waiting list to just be like, part of the exclusive Disney VIP club.
What is that?
It's basically... Oh my god, he's so strong!
Like...
What?
Okay.
Level 34.
Maybe I'll just use stick bug.
Club 32.
So there's this Disney club called Club 32.
And like...
Each year, you have to pay a very expensive membership.
Oh my god, you're gonna die.
You have to pay for like...
A...
Very...
Oh, 33.
Sorry.
Club 33.
And each year, you have to pay a very, very expensive membership to be in the club.
But there's also a 10...
I think it was like, eight plus year plus waiting list to even be part of the...
Uh...
Part of the club.
And yet to be referred to by other members in Club 33.
And like...
I killed him.
I...
Fuck!
No!
I...
I don't know!
I was trying to find anything that could do a little damage!
I...
Oh, and I fell down again.
I fell down again.
Okay, and they would have like, exclusive merch there.
And you could like...
Oh my gosh.
I like, rattled up a little bit.
But they can kick you out at any moment.
I didn't know.
I didn't...
Oh my god, I went through the same...
I can't help it!
Wait, is there any like, mons in this cave?
Oh no, this cave is...
Is like, free.
I...
I just went through the same hole.
The same fucking hole.
What are the benefits?
Okay, give me a sec.
Let me like, run away.
And I'll show you...
I'll explain Club 33.
I know you guys really wanna know what's in Club 33.
Now.
Alright.
So, Club 33.
There's like, lounges everywhere.
You can get like, tickets and stuff.
Okay.
Club 33.
What's...
What do you get?
What do you get in Club...
How much do...
Alright.
Okay.
So, the initiation fee is...
Fifty...
Okay.
The initiation fee...
Can be as high as...
Fifteen...
Thousand...
Dollars.
And membership fee...
Is...
Fifteen...
Thousand...
Dollars?
Holy...
Fuck.
Jesus.
Okay.
I didn't know...
I didn't even know that.
Okay.
That's a lot.
Disney adults are scary.
Disney...
Disney adults are really scary.
Alright.
It's a most...
It's an exclusive and mysterious members only club.
Don't talk about it.
It stays low with...
Oh yeah.
You have to have a dress code too.
Um...
Fifteen as in...
One five...
Three zero.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Jesus.
What the...
I did not realize...
It was...
That expensive.
Holy...
Shit.
Yeah.
You should get...
Club 33 is like...
Crazy.
A crazy experience.
That's why I'm like...
I'm afraid of Disney adults.
Don't go through that hole again.
Yeah.
There's like a lounge and exclusive merch you can buy...
And everything.
Apparently like...
A lot of celebrities are in Club 33.
I don't like this one bit.
What's that?
Toadra is looking for me back into...
Therion?
Thanks.
I was a little scared to leave on my own.
Are you here?
I think I can do it.
Nice.
We did it.
Yeah.
Pay money to spend more money.
Do I need that item?
I feel like I don't.
I saved all...
I did it!
I'm a hero!
I saved all the toads!
Oh nice.
There's Iron Cleft again.
Okay.
This time I won't kill him.
Yeah but regular people can get in too.
Quote on quote regular.
There's...
I only knew about Club 33 because like...
A couple got kicked out of Club 33.
And they spent all their money trying to sue Disney to allow them back into Club 33.
And then because like...
They couldn't get back into Club 33.
The reason why...
They got like kicked out was because apparently the husband...
Seemed like he was like intoxicated in public at Disneyland.
So then they got kicked out because of that.
And then because they tried to sue...
Disneyland...
To like...
To like make them...
Get them back into Club 33.
That like...
After they lost the case...
Um...
They revealed everything.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
They whistle blown Club 33.
And like revealed everything about it.
But it's crazy.
They sued Disney to try to...
Get back into Club 33.
I feel like that's crazy.
The crazy part.
And then they were like...
I didn't want to talk about this.
Like I really wanted to get back into Club 33.
But they made us no choice.
So we're revealing everything.
There's not a secret society about it anymore.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
I feel like I am.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
An ad that works staff in Disney one.
She mentioned Disney dolls were always the hardest to work with.
Um...
Does Disney have any...
Yeah, they know.
They run the club.
They actually run the club.
A bald cleft with spikes for a while.
Only two members of this species had ever been countered.
They used their hard iron coding to fight for sport.
Wait only...
For a while?
Only two members?
I like killed so many.
There's a reason why there's only two left of this species.
I...
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
The scientists were only able to document two.
Because I've killed the others.
Ha ha ha.
You're the one I left alive.
Okay.
I left you alive so you can tell the tale.
I wonder what's up with this tower.
I can't understand a single thing on these weird rocks.
Oh, what?
The secret tower?
I was told that I could get to Metro Kingdom through this tower.
There's no way to the top.
What a scam.
This rock is quite mysterious.
I see it has special healing properties.
Making this a risk stop of sorts for travelers.
Oh, okay.
That's good.
Yeah.
I'm sorry, but it seems the path to Metro Kingdom hasn't closed off by Kamek.
If only there's something we could do.
Oh, there's nothing I could do?
Yup, no witnesses.
And yeah, thank you for giving us a super chat.
Thank you.
Yup.
You're here forever.
Uh-huh.
Ha-ha-ha-ha.
Goofy dog.
Ha-ha-ha.
What was that?
Mickey and Goofy in Vietnam video?
Ha-ha.
Gosh, Mickey, we gotta report this.
Oh, gosh.
Ha-ha.
Ha-ha-ha.
Yeah.
Oh.
Uh-huh.
Goofy.
I thought you were different?
Ha-ha-ha.
Ha-ha-ha-ha.
Take the shot, Mickey.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha.
Ha-ha-ha-ha.
The- leverage for those who have never seen that video..
I think you can.
It's called Mickey and Goofy in Vietnam.
It's an animation.
It's a classic, it's a classic.
Obviously, they're a lot better.
They sound more like Goofy and Mickey than me, obviously.
Is that not all of them?!
I'm not... What?
Who else is missing?
What are you talking about?
Look up Goofy and Mickey in Vietnam.
And then you'll know what I'm talking about.
How many more toes am I missing?
Oh my god.
I thought I found all of them.
I hate this area.
Go to the tower?
I was in the tower.
They're like, I don't know what to do.
And I was like, I don't know what to do either.
There's some crazy... I saw some shorts.
Some, um, Disney shorts.
Of, like, what it was like to be, like, an ex-Disney princess.
Um, an ex-Disney princess for Disneyland.
And, like, some of the rules were fucking crazy.
Oh, wait, there were rocks?!
Oh my god, wait, there is!
I can't read!
Is this lost?
Is this...
What am I reading?
Braille?
Am I reading lost?
One of them has to be lost.
Wait...
Change rocks, right?
I knew...
Wait, that was lost!
Oh my god!
Oh, I wrote this game.
I...
Change rocks, right?
Don't worry if you can't solve the riddle.
Mario!
The ancient Tostarian language has been lost for years.
I caught up an archaeologist to help us out with the tower.
And they should be here any moment.
I should be the...
No!
Oh my god.
I knew it.
I saw those Braille.
I knew Lost was in here.
Mario!
You're here too?
You know the captain, Mario?
Of course we know each other!
We just went through the entire jungle!
That's what had you away for so long, eh?
Well, never mind!
We got a puzzle that needs solving!
Right!
The Tostarian rocks!
Right?
This one's easy.
No!
Why is he back?
All I gotta do is touch all rocks and go to the center one!
Huh?
Now all I gotta do is touch this one and the way should be open!
Oh nice.
Whoa!
Where did that ladder come from?
Ha!
I knew it!
That'll lead you right to the top of the tower!
You want me to come with you?
Oh no!
No!
I'll be heading back into the desert!
Besides, you shouldn't really rely on me too much!
I'm sure we'll get a chance to work together sometime in the future!
But right now, let's go bye once more!
Oh thank god!
Good god!
Better not waste any time!
Come is up there and needs to be stopped!
What?
Okay.
Thank god.
Was I lost?
Or was lost?
Oh there it is!
There it is!
Yeah, that's lost!
I knew it!
I can smell lost a mile away!
It's so easy!
Any time!
There's stuff like that!
Lost will always be there!
What is lost?
Lost?
L-O-S-S It's an infamous webcomic back then where it was originally made to be like...
Haha!
I'm a nerd!
I make relatable nerd comics!
And then like...
And then all of a sudden...
He decided to make it like...
Serious!
And then like...
He got his girlfriend pregnant!
And he lo- And she lost a baby!
And...
But then like...
The...
The whole webcomic before then...
Was...
Haha!
Funny nerd relatable shit!
Like...
So everyone was like...
Why...
Why was there...
Didn't...
There was no joke!
It was just...
She had a miscarriage!
Like...
And then everyone was...
And then it just...
Every...
It just became lost!
Haha!
It was so...
I don't know...
I forgot this guy...
It does not have...
So I was so busy talking about lost...
I didn't...
Oh my god!
What worked?
I...
Okay...
Let me...
Bye!
Haha!
Okay...
Something worked!
Something...
Oh...
Jesus!
But...
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Okay...
Yeah...
Lost...
Is like...
The...
The name of the comic book...
Comic series itself!
Yay!
Alright...
Who wants to be it?
Chincho!
A mummy that charges at you with adorable Bannon!
Scientists still don't know what that creature was!
It has the cutest smile!
But I'll never show you!
Oh, it's like a little ghost!
Alright...
You know what?
Put in...
I'll give it to you!
Who...
We're in...
...
There we go!
Yay!
Okay, we gotta go this way!
Oh...
These ice levels are so easy!
I feel like I've been molded by them!
We're just over here!
I've been molded by these ice levels!
Why is it...
So...
So cold!
I think I'm going to freeze it!
I'm going to be able to wait out of here!
It's a...
It's such...
It's a classic ice puzzle from Pokemon!
Oh my god!
Look at him!
I wanna melt it!
But I gotta catch it!
Alright!
Get in my ball!
Pa-dump!
Click!
Yeah!
Alright!
Who wants to be the freezy?
The cold never bothered me anyway!
And any of pure ice!
It freezes any living thing it touches!
Locals are warned to stay away from them!
A nice hot bath can easily defrost anyone!
Alright!
Let's see you!
Well, it hasn't been named yet.
I've already lost track.
Again.
You know what?
Alright, Stray.
I'll give it to you.
Stray.
Seijin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh!
Next time.
Next one I catch.
Stray.
Goon.
But I gotta be reminded.
Alright.
Next one I'll catch.
Okay.
I'm just going by random.
Sometimes I do super chat, sometimes I pick randomly.
It's how I feel.
It's a feeling.
You just keep you guessing, you know?
It's like, gotcha.
Gotta keep you on your toes.
It's a vibe.
Haha, Teehee, you're so random.
Oh my god, Teehee, you're so creepy and random.
Okay.
Let's see.
Sorry, I have to...
Alright.
Yes, I did it.
Lowes random, XD.
You're plotting as Mario will not be getting to the...
...Metro Kingdom any time soon.
Eek!
Mario!
You got here quickly!
No time for games.
Your defeat will be swift.
Eek!
Petal!
Roar XD!
So random!
XD XD!
Sorry, I just made everybody, like...
Remember...
I remember back then, when I was on the Neopets, Neoports chat rooms.
I would spam, like, XD...
Like, act like, XDs all the time.
Zom's epic!
What happened to you at the hair salon?
They put a hair dye, and then, like, it burned my scalp a little.
I lied.
Okay, that was...
It's weird.
It wasn't the hair dye that burned my scalp.
It was when I was, like, shampooing.
And I have no idea what product they put in my hair when they were shampooing my hair.
And, like...
But, like, it, like, burned my scalp.
I have no idea what they used.
It wasn't even the hair dye.
Like, I have no idea.
Oh my god.
Bro, why are you setting ice...
Bro, my main...
Main mod is literally fire.
Uh, candies.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, I heard about that.
And then, like, I heard that...
It's so awkward.
Cause, like...
Wait, what the fuck?
Why didn't it hit?
Guys, I didn't read.
Oh, why didn't it hit?
I read that, like...
Um...
Wait, what?
It doesn't do anything, but he's ice!
What the fuck?
But your ice!
He's heavier.
There's no way!
Eat more!
Keep eating!
Heheheheh.
Gheheheh.
Heheheh.
But like...
I heard...
Bungie canceled all marketing for the game...
Recently, afterwards.
Heheheh.
So like...
That's awkward.
Pool strength slowly...
Sorry!
But lowers abilities.
Wait, what does that mean?
How does it lower my ability?
Yeah, they recently shut it down afterwards.
Oh, and those attack?
Oh, it's bad?
Oh, okay.
I'm getting it out of there.
You seem like the Penguin Doom kind of gal.
I had no idea what the fuck that was.
But someone asked me to fucking say... You know who you are.
But in the custom voice pack, I had to record that...
Um, I had to record that shitpost.
I have no idea what that was.
Yes, someone requested that as a custom voice pack.
And I like, listened to it.
I like, listened to it.
And I was like, what the fuck?
I don't remember who it was, but you know who you are.
You know who you are.
The first I requested it.
I released the footage.
Wait, there's voice packs?
Gavin, thank you for Super Chat.
Thank you.
Oh, it was like the... It was the custom anniversary voice pack.
I did like 69... Wait, no.
I did 54 of them.
I only sold 54.
Because it was a lot.
And I'm very busy.
Mayo, still as strong as ever.
Beating me doesn't melt the ice.
There he is.
Get him!
Beat him up!
Beat up the nerd!
Beat him... Oh my god!
Oh my god!
They're like, Jojo beating him up.
Got his wand!
Got your nose!
Hee hee!
Now, how does this thing work?
Take his shoes!
Yeah!
Get that nerd!
No, you're doing it all wrong!
You have to set it to I for ice!
What about W for wombo?
When it should be set to I for incinerary!
Are you serious?
Is this the face of someone who is serious?
Oh wait!
It's right here!
Let's go, everyone!
Atom, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I made Doki sing Maroon 5.
Oh yeah!
He made me sing Anima.
Mario, you'll pay for this!
So he backs up.
Alright, never melt ice.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Talking about custom voice packs.
Thank you so much for mine!
And sorry for making you create the script for me.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's alright.
I didn't even create a script.
I just...
Oh yeah, some people asked me to create a scenario or something.
But like, majority of the time, when they want me to create a script, I just...
Just wing it.
Okay, they paid me 69.69 dollars.
Don't worry, Silent Snake.
Oh!
It's Shroob!
Okay, that's you, Shijin.
You're gonna be Last of Us.
Put him in.
Oh wait, you're so over-leveled.
Holy shit.
When the heck did Heftly get so over-leveled?
Oh.
True!
Silent Snake!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh god, you poor soul.
I'm sorry, and I wasn't even you.
Ha ha ha ha.
Oh.
Okay, I have to actually damage it.
But like...
I have to damage it, but like, I cannot use Heftly.
Because Heftly is too...
Too strong.
Oh, everyone is too strong!
I love the little song.
Oh my...
You're gonna...
You're gonna go back in the box.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
You're gonna...
Ooh...
Ha ha ha ha ha!
You've disappointed me for the last time!
Ha ha ha ha!
Turkey, please trust us.
He's strong!
He's not...
You're gonna...
You're gonna go back to the box.
Ha ha ha ha!
I've seen enough.
You've had one too many...
You two had one too many chances.
Ha ha ha ha!
You're just using it wrong!
If He doesn't work the way I want it to work...
Then I...
Then it's not my fault!
Ha ha ha ha!
Alright.
Baseball cap time.
And even though you were in my party...
You don't get the luxury of being in the cave.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
You don't get that luxury.
Zoniman, thank you to the super chat.
Thank you.
Where are these voice backs so I can avoid them?
And are these lucky bastards allowed to share them?
If they want to.
They can do what they want.
As long as they don't monetize it.
Uh...
Alright, hopefully you're gonna be there to...
You're gonna be there to, like, get captured.
To help me just throw rocks at...
Uh, throw caps at them.
Sorry, not rocks.
I'm only doing custom voice backs for, like, special occasions.
Just cause they do take a lot...
Of time...
To record, in general.
So, for it, it was, like, an anniversary thing.
Uh, Papa Smurf, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thanks for the gym motivation, Doki.
Yeah!
An alien from the shrew planet.
It speaks an unknown language.
It's rumored to have access to unbelievably advanced technology and weapons.
All it does is spit poison.
It just spits acid.
What do you mean, technology?
Alright.
How do you...
What, Shijun?
How do you spell your name?
Or, Seijun?
See...
Seijun.
Good.
Alright.
Alright, I got it right.
I spelled it correctly, too.
Oh, nice, max rappel.
Nice.
Alright, get it over here.
There has to be a heal, like, at...
Um...
There has to be a hill.
At the top of the tower, right?
Oh, goodbye dad.
Oh wait, no, you're fine.
Alright, now it's goodbye.
Okay, no, never mind.
Oh, shit.
That's fine.
Now it's goodbye.
Goodbye.
You don't matter to me.
Oh, it's New Dog City!
Nothing's biting me.
I just don't got it anymore.
Take my rock.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Don't ask.
Whoa, okay.
Alright, where is the... Whoa.
Alright, let's put down the slag.
We made it!
Wait, okay, we gotta do a Pokemon Center.
Crazy cat.
The fuck?
You get run over?
No.
My second airplane tag!
Don't get in our way!
Oh, they lost.
Oh, you lost tag.
Hey, you lost, though.
I got in the way.
Nice ride, bro.
Thanks, a stranger gave it to me.
Where the fuck is the Pokemon Center?
Oh my god, I'm so lost in the city.
Okay, there's Pauline and Luigi.
Where the fuck is the...
Where's the... Okay, I'm trying to find a Pokemon Center before I talk to the Toads.
Is it a crazy cat?
Oh, is that it?
I couldn't tell.
It's just yellow and purple.
Oh my god, it is.
Oh, they like linked together.
That's all the caps I want?
Oh, it's a better cap.
Wait, I need that.
Okay, nice.
Let's buy that.
That's all we need.
All right.
Let's heal our tired mons.
All right, guys.
I'm going to call it here because tomorrow's a very long day.
Tomorrow's going to be a very long day, so I'm going to call it here.
I would stream longer, but like...
If I didn't have like...
If I didn't have like double streams tomorrow.
And I want to see if I can finish Onimushu 2.
Yes, they said it's like a...
I read the thing and it's like five to six...
I don't know.
Five to eight hours depending on how poorly I do.
It's like Onimushu.
Oh my god, I'm doing what I did in the past.
Guys, you remember what I kept saying Onimushu in the beginning when I first played?
Oh my god.
Blast from the past.
Anyway, the past repeats itself.
But yes, I'm playing that tomorrow.
Old habits die hard.
Anyway, guys, thank you all for coming for today.
I had a fun time playing some more Super Mario mod.
I believe we have...
Well, we have three more worlds left.
So let's hope we can finish another world next playthrough.
And then get closer and closer to the end.
Hey guys, as always everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.